bien
mes chers collègues nous allons
ouvrir cette séance d'audition
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
mes chers collègues
nous avons le plaisir ce matin
d'accueillir monsieur Mathieu Chabanel
président directeur général de SNCF
réseau
il me semble qu'il s'agit monsieur
Chabanel de votre premier audition
devant une commission parlementaire
cela s'explique notamment par le fait
que la nomination du PDG de SNCF réseau
n'est plus soumise depuis 2020 ou
contrôle les commissions compétentes en
application de l'article 13 de la
Constitution
nous étions d'ailleurs fermement opposés
à l'occasion d'examens des projets de
loi organique et ordinaire nos dixième
mandelier était rapporteur pour avis à
cette réduction à justifier du contrôle
parlementaire sur les nominations des
dirigeants du groupe SNCF le Parlement
exerçait ce droit de regard depuis 2010
sur la nomination du président de Réseau
ferré de France RFF l'ancêtre de SNCF
réseau cette évolution ne nous a pas
pour autant empêché d'auditionner vos
prédécesseurs monsieur Luc Lallemand
dessin nomination en 2020 ainsi qu'en
février 2022 à l'occasion de la révision
du contrat de performance entre l'État
SNCF réseau la Commission avait à
l'époque conduit un cycle d'audition sur
ce nouveau contrat qui avait alors fait
l'unanimité contre lui dans les
opérateurs de transport de fret et de
voyageurs que le régulateur les
collectivités territoriales et les
usagers s'accordaient pour en souligner
les insuffisances
le président de l'Autorité de régulation
des transports Monsieur Bernard Roman
évoquait alors une occasion manquée pour
le faire revenir
un an plus tard les termes du débat ont
beaucoup évolué la publication du
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures le COI voilà quelques
semaines ainsi que les annonces de la
première ministre sur le transport
ferroviaire ont changé la donne et
laisse augurer de possibles
améliorations du réseau ferroviaire tant
d'un point de vue de la régénération que
de sa modernisation
c'est pourquoi nous souhaiterions vous
entendre sur le devenir de ce contrat à
court et moyen terme et sur la
traduction concrète de ces récents
engagements politiques consistant à
débloquer 100 milliards d'euros d'ici
2040 pour réussir une nouvelle donne
ferroviaire aussi monsieur le Président
Directeur Général ma question ma
première question sera simple est-il
prévu de réviser le contrat de
performance entre l'État et SNCF réseau
et si oui dans quel délai
en outre la question centrale qui
demeure à ce stade en suspense et celle
du comment comment et par qui
précisément seront financés c'est 100
milliards d'euros jusqu'à présent la
régénération du réseau repose en France
sur les pH ferroviaires malgré le niveau
de pH le plus élevé d'Europe l'état de
notre réseau ferroviaire est
particulièrement alarmant et de
nouvelles augmentations des péages
seraient tout simplement insoutenable
pour les régions et pour les opérateurs
la modernisation du réseau ne fait quant
à elle l'objet d'aucun modèle de
financement à long terme
dans ce contexte estimez-vous que les
récentes annonces sont l'occasion de
remettre à plat le modèle de financement
du transport ferroviaire avez-vous
travaillé à des propositions en la
matière je souhaiterais par ailleurs
vous interroger sur le déploiement des
RER métropolitains annoncés par le
Président de la République et pour
lesquels la première ministre indiquée
souhaitait s'appuyer sur l'expertise de
la Société du Grand Paris comment
avez-vous accueilli cette annonce
SNCF réseau avait d'ores et déjà
travaillé sur ce sujet et publié en 2020
schéma directeur sur les étoiles
ferroviaires et les services express
métropolitain aussi voyez-vous dans
cette annonce une forme de concurrence
ou au contraire une forme de
complémentarité et comment
envisagez-vous l'articulation entre SNCF
réseau et la Société du Grand Paris
peut-on y voir un risque en matière
d'unicité et de cohérence du réseau
ferroviaire
enfin ma dernière question porte sur le
véhicule législatif qui sera privilégié
pour traduire ces dernières annonces en
matière de transport
dispensez-vous dispensez-vous et
disposez-vous d'informations à ce sujet
il nous semble collectivement qu'une loi
de programmation
dédiée au transport serait le véhicule
le plus efficace étant donné que les
infrastructures de transport par
définition doivent reposer sur des
engagements crédibles de temps long
monsieur le Président je vous remercie
et je vous souhaite de la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs d'abord merci de me permettre
d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui quelques
mois après ma nomination à la tête de
SNCF réseau pour vous présenter
l'ambition de l'entreprise la situation
du réseau est naturellement et d'abord
pour répondre à vos questions aussi je
m'efforcerai que mon propos liminaire
soit soit le plus bref possible et je
l'articulerai autour de deux trois
points un retour sur les ambitions de
SNCF réseau et les principales
orientations un premier bilan après
quelques mois des attentes que j'ai pu
percevoir vis-à-vis de notre entreprise
et enfin un point sur les actions que
nous avons engagé d'abord l'ambition de
SNCF réseau elle se place naturellement
dans le nouveau cadre qui s'est mis en
place en 2020
et elle s'inscrit dans la volonté de la
SNCF réseau d'être non pas une
entreprise de travaux mais bien un
gestionnaire d'infrastructures dans
lequel 53000 hommes et femmes s'emploie
chaque jour à faire circuler 15000
trains dans les meilleures conditions de
sécurité et de régularité sur le réseau
ferré national alors 4 principes
inspirent inspirent notre action ces
principes étant tous basés sur le la
volonté d'ouverture de l'entreprise et
la volonté d'adresser les défis de
demain alors le premier principe c'est
c'est le lien entre SNCF réseau les
territoires et les parties prenantes je
pense que SNCF réseau est une entreprise
par nature territoriale le réseau
s'étend sur 30 000 kilomètres de lignes
il traverse 8800 communes
j'allais dire on ne peut pas diriger
SNCF réseau si on n'aime pas et si on ne
connaît pas la géographie de la France
on est sur une entreprise qui doit
renforcer
de son lien avec les territoires avec
l'ensemble des acteurs des territoires
naturellement les collectivités
territoriales mais aussi l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques en territoire que ce
soit les utilisateurs de nos moyens de
transport aussi bien en voyageurs quand
marchandise que ce soit les entreprises
ferroviaires dans un paysage qui s'ouvre
à la concurrence mais que ce soit aussi
l'ensemble des entreprises qui
travaillent sur le réseau ferré-national
pour nous fournir des matériaux pour
nous fournir des prestations de travaux
pour nous fournir des
prestations intellectuelles c'est aussi
un travail avec les associations sur les
territoires je signais
avant-hier un nouveau partenariat avec
l'association France Nature
Environnement parce qu'on sait que et
j'y reviendrai l'intégration du réseau
dans son environnement est un enjeu
essentiel ce dialogue renforcé avec les
territoires et notamment avec les
autorités organisatrices il se traduit
au travers de nombreux projet s des
projets d'infrastructures bien sûr mais
aussi des projets de service notamment
pour préparer l'ouverture à la
concurrence du transport conventionné
ce dialogue je le disais il s'exerce
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire et il s'exerce aussi avec la
filière industrielle du ferroviaire
les investissements dans le réseau et je
vais y revenir ça faisait partie de vos
de vos questions monsieur le Président
les investissements dans le réseau sont
nécessaires et sont importants ils se
sont élevés en 2022 à 5,5 milliards
d'euros sur le périmètre de SNCF réseau
un milliard de plus si on prend en
compte notre filiale SNCF gare et
connexion ce sont prêts donc près de 6
milliards et demi d'euros qui ont été
investis par le groupe SNCF réseau sur
le territoire national en 2022 ce sera
plus de 7 milliards en 2023 et s'il y
avait un chiffre à retenir c'est que
quand SNCF réseau investit un euro c'est
20% de ma salariale de SNCF réseau mais
c'est 80% d'achat auprès d'entreprises
extérieures de fournisseurs de rails de
traverse de ballast d'équipement de
signalisation de prestations travaux de
prestations intellectuelle et donc c'est
tout un écosystème qui vit des
investissements dans le réseau ferré
national et un écosystème largement
français puisque 97% de nos fournisseurs
sont français et 20% plus de 20% de nos
fournisseurs sont des PME donc les
investissements dans le réseau
ferrénational qui sont répartis sur
l'ensemble du territoire contribue à une
dynamique économique et SNCF réseau à un
vrai rôle d'animateur de cette filière
économique essentielle pour l'activité
nationale
alors ce rôle il doit l'exercer tout en
étant le plus performant possible c'est
la troisième orientation les territoires
la filière industrielle la troisième
orientation c'est la performance qui est
attendue de nous naturellement nous nous
inscrivons dans le cadre du retour à
l'équilibre puisque nous sommes une
société anonyme et donc nous devons
revenir à un équilibre économique en
2024 puis en 2026
équilibré économique qui est permis
d'une part par le désendettement de
train à hauteur de 35 milliards d'euros
qui a été mis en place par l'État dans
le cadre de la loi pacte ferroviaire
mais aussi par la performance de SNCF
réseau qui doit atteindre 1,5 milliards
d'euros par an en 2026 nous en sommes
déjà à 940 millions d'euros par an en
2022 donc nous sommes sur la bonne
trajectoire pour le moment nous avons
tenu nos objectifs de performance et il
faut poursuivre dans cette voie ses
objectifs de performance sont des
objectifs de performance économique mais
qui reposent naturellement sur des
programmes industriels c'est pas de la
performance qu'on peut faire dans des
tableaux Excel elle doit se voir dans
les contes à la fin mais c'est pas de la
performance qu'on peut faire au siège de
SNCF réseau à Saint-Denis c'est bien sûr
le terrain en cherchant à être le plus
efficace possible qu'on réussit cette
performance je vais en prendre deux
illustrations importantes en 2022 la
commande centralisée du réseau dans mon
prédécesseur avait pu vous parler en
2022 on a remplacé 8 postes
d'aiguillages dans la zone de Valence
par deux postes informatiques et qu'on a
centralisé à Lyon ça a permis à la fois
des économies importantes et
modernisation importante de
l'exploitation dans cette zone et donc
ce sont bien c'est ces projets
industriels qui tirent notre performance
économique de la même manière en 2022
nous avons supprimé 120 appareils de
voix 120 aiguillages sur le réseau
entretenir chaque année un aiguillage ça
coûte 17000 euros on doit donc en avoir
le bon nombre ni trop ni pas assez pour
avoir une exploitation la plus fluide
possible mais pour ne pas
penser des sommes et qui ne seraient pas
justifiées et donc là aussi en
supprimant ces 120 aiguillages on a
généré de la performance et des
économies et ce sont bien les programmes
industriels qui vont tirer cette
performance économique dernière axe les
territoires la filière industrielle la
performance économique des rails notre
transition écologique vous le savez vous
je sais que vous le défendez le train
est un mode
de transport qui est bon pour la planète
par ses émissions de carbone par sa
consommation d'énergie mais ça ne doit
pas exonérer SNCF réseau de travailler
sur son propre impact sur
l'environnement on est une entreprise
qui fait je vous l'ai dit beaucoup de
travaux qui a une répartition sur
l'ensemble du territoire et donc il faut
qu'on regarde dans nos modes
d'exploitation comment on peut diminuer
leur impact sur l'environnement deux
actions qu'on a conduites en 2022 nous
sommes sortis du glyphosate nous sommes
le 1er gestionnaire d'infrastructures
européen ferroviaire à l'avoir fait nous
n'utilisons plus depuis le 1er janvier
2022 de glyphosate sur le réseau ferré
national c'est une action en faveur en
faveur de l'environnement et et autres
actions tout le travail que nous faisons
en matière d'économie circulaire pour
utiliser moins de le moins de matériaux
possibles et je vais prendre l'exemple
du rail aujourd'hui pour le rail on a
une filière qui avec l'usine d'alliance
qui est une usine française qui nous
fournit en rail depuis le début du 20e
siècle avec l'usine d'Hayange nous le
rachetons du rail qui provient pour
partie d'acier
issus de la Syrie électrique daskoval et
donc beaucoup moins émetteur de carbone
que des acieries traditionnelles et
cette série électrique elle se fournit
en ferraille notamment de rails auprès
de nous donc on a des circuits
circulaires qui font qu'on vend du rail
qui est refondu en acier qui ensuite
refondu en rail et qui ensuite refondu
revendu à SNCF réseau et ça ça permet de
consommer beaucoup moins de matière
beaucoup moins de carbone mais c'est bon
à la fois pour nos économies et pour la
planète donc voilà les ambitions
stratégiques de de SNCF réseau
aujourd'hui elle repose et elle ne
pourront se développer que si nous
remplissons deux prérequis le premier
c'est la sécurité
c'est le socle de toute exploitation
ferroviaire on sait que si on n'est pas
au rendez-vous sur la sécurité toutes
les ambitions qu'on peut avoir pour le
réseau
c'est s'évanouiront c'est vraiment le
premier prérequis et le deuxième
pré-requis c'est d'avoir au sein de SNCF
réseau et dans la filière des hommes et
des femmes qui se sentent bien dans
l'entreprise et donc de réussir le
triptyque autour du recrutement de la
formation et de la fidélisation c'est un
enjeu important d'attractivité des
métiers du ferroviaire dans un marché de
l'emploi qui est aujourd'hui tendu
notamment dans les métiers techniques
comment on attire les talents et les
compétences de tout niveau de
qualification au sein de la filière
ferroviaire alors voilà quel en quelques
mots sur les ambitions
[Musique]
sont dans une situation plus positive et
dans une dynamique plus positive autour
d'un certain nombre de grands projets et
puis le deuxième axe et j'en arrive à
vos questions monsieur le Président le
deuxième axe a été de convaincre des
besoins du réseau il y avait tout un
travail qui avait qui avait été fait le
Sénat l'Autorité de régulation des
transports avait déjà porté haut et
forts les besoins du réseau dans les
mois qui ont de la fin de l'année et du
début de cette année ça a été l'occasion
de le de le redire le contrat de
performance vous l'avez dit donner de la
visibilité il avait le mérite de la
sincérité mais il traduisait aussi le
fait qu'avec les moyens du contrat de
performance le réseau allait continuer à
vieillir et donc la performance du
réseau n'allait dans les années à venir
passe améliorer et voire même lentement
se dégrader le COI a parfaitement pris
conscience de cette situation et les
annonces de la première ministre il y a
quelques semaines on traduit la volonté
du gouvernement de s'inscrire dans les
recommandations du coi c'est
recommandations elles sont autour de
trois axes d'abord un effort
complémentaire pour la régénération du
réseau pour éviter cette lente
dégradation c'est un milliard d'euros de
plus à l'horizon 2027 qui devront être
investis chaque année dans la
régénération du réseau deuxièmement un
enjeu de modernisation de manière à ce
que le réseau français soit un réseau
qui reste dans la course des réseaux
européens en matière de digitalisation
et ça se traduit notamment par les
programmes de concentration des postes
d'aiguillages au sein des commandes
centralisées du réseau et d'autre part
du programme de déploiement du système
de signalisation européen ERTMS
oui au jour enfin aujourd'hui
donc le programme vise à nous remettre
dans la course à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros de modernisation à l'horizon de
2027 et puis enfin des projets de
développement tournés autour d'une part
des RER métropolitain et d'autre part de
la poursuite d'un certain nombre de
grands projets
portés par par les territoires donc nous
travaillons d'ores et déjà à la montée
en charge de ce programme
d'investissement à l'horizon de de 2027
c'est un défi industriel important pour
SNCF réseau mais pour toute la filière
industrielle parce que comme je vous le
disais c'est pas SNCF réseau avec ses
moyens qui va réussir à faire un
milliard et demi d'euros
d'investissement en plus c'est SNCF
réseau et toute une filière
d'entreprises d'ingénierie de travaux de
fournitures de matériaux qui vont
réussir cette MONT cette montée
industrielle c'est un défi industriel
qui se double d'un défi organisationnel
puisqu'il s'agit naturellement pas que
ces travaux
pénalisent de manière excessive les
circulations que ce soit les
circulations de voyageurs ou les
circulations de frais et donc il va
falloir combiner la montée en charge des
travaux et le maintien d'un niveau de
circulation suffisant sur le réseau donc
les équipes de SNCF réseau sur ce sur ce
plan là sont particulièrement motivés
elles ont la volonté de réussir ce défi
et elles sont déjà aujourd'hui en train
de s'organiser pour pouvoir à l'horizon
de l'été à l'horizon du moment où la
réflexion sur les financements qui a été
annoncé par la première ministre prendra
accord être au rendez-vous du lancement
de ces grands programmes industriels qui
doivent s'inscrire dans une logique de
visibilité et de prévisibilité pour les
années à venir si on veut réussir ce
fantastique défi pour le réseau
ferroviaire national voilà ce que je
pouvais peut-être dire monsieur le
Président en propos liminaire avant de
vous laisser en venir aux questions et
de répondre plus précisément aux
questions que vous aviez posé vous-même
dans votre dans votre introduction merci
monsieur le Président je vais donner la
parole rapporteur je lui donne la parole
à Philippe Tabaro
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président vous en conviendrez le
contexte dans lequel nous vous
additionnons est a priori plus
encourageant que lorsque nous avions
reçu votre prédécesseur monsieur
l'allemand sur la révision du contrat de
performance votre prédécesseur avait
peut-être le défaut d'être trop honnête
puisqu'il reconnaissait devant notre
commission je le cite nous nous
contenterons des moyens à louer voilà
qui était clair et c'est peut-être en
partie ce qui lui a valu d'être débarqué
en septembre 2022 car Luc Lallemand
avoué quelque part la Mission Impossible
qui était la sienne celle d'assurer la
régénération du réseau voire même sa
modernisation sans qu'on lui en donne
les moyens pour y parvenir à la lumière
des dernières évolutions je souhaiterais
vous entendre avec la même honnêteté
avez-vous eu des promesses de moyens
supplémentaires pour revenir à la tête
d'une maison que vous aviez quitté
d'abord sur les 100 milliards promis par
la première ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire qu'elle part reviendra qu'elle
financeur et quelle sera la trajectoire
d'évolution des péages associés les
régions particuliers ne seraient
absorbées de nouvelles hausses de pH a
été dit par le président Joe et cela
entraverait sans aucun doute l'ouverture
à la concurrence ensuite avec ces
montants qu'elle pourrait être
l'objectif en matière de régénération du
réseau je rappelle vous l'avez dit que
notre réseau est vieillissant qu'il
continue de se dégrader aussi quelle
mesure peut-on espérer une augmentation
de l'indice de consistance de la voix je
m'inquiète un petit peu vous avez parlé
certes d'un milliard supplémentaire mais
en 2027 ce qui veut dire qu'on va passer
encore
trois voire quatre années sans
investissement supplémentaire et avec ce
contrat non pas de performance mais de
contre-performance si j'ai mal
interprété vos propos pouvez-vous s'il
vous plaît préciser les choses dans ce
contexte nous espérons tous la révision
de ce contrat de performance
ce sera l'occasion notamment définir une
véritable stratégie de modernisation du
réseau là aussi je vais pas revenir sur
ce qui a été dit vous avez parlé de
rester dans la course et c'est ce qui a
valu que notre collègue gilet corrige un
petit peu les choses comment peut-on
dire rester dans la course alors qu'on a
le bonnet d'âne européen avec une
absence criante de vision stratégique et
industrielle en la matière notamment sur
la commande centralisée du réseau alors
vous avez fait 8 postes cette année vous
en êtes très content et on l'est
également mais quand on sait que que la
Suisse a achevé à 100%
la commande centralisée de son réseau
l'Allemagne à 90% et qu'au rythme où on
va on serait équipé en 2070
au vu des dernières annonces aussi
comment voyez-vous les choses sur la
modernisation au niveau de l'ERTMS où là
également nous avons pris pas mal de
retard concernant la question que vous a
posé le le président jauge reviendrai à
l'instant dessus sur le déploiement
de nous dire comment vous vivez la
mission qui a été confiée à la Société
du Grand Paris ne pensez-vous pas que
c'est une mise sous tutelle SNCF réseau
un aveu d'échec ou bien de lucidité sur
le fret enfin est-il bien
cohérent de pensées qu'on peut atteindre
l'objectif que nous avons souhaité dans
cette maison de doublement de la part
modale du rail d'ici 2030 et pour
conclure que répondez-vous à ceux qui
préconisent de sortir désormais la
filiale SNCF réseau du groupe SNCF pour
la rendre réellement indépendante à
l'image de ce qui existe déjà dans le
secteur de l'électricité entre RTE et
EDF
et enfin monsieur le Président ça fait
quoi d'être allégé du poids d'une dette
de 35 milliards
la parole à une série de cinq de mes
collègues puisqu'il y a 15 demande de
parole donc on va faire trois séries on
va essayer d'être
regroupé un peu les choses et
effectivement d'être synthétique si
possible merci merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur Tabaro
effectivement alors je vais essayer
d'être tout aussi honnête que que que
mon prédécesseur dans dans la on
souhaite pas les mêmes conséquences pour
vous si vous
donnez ça peut vous permettre de rester
en poste n'hésitez pas à être un peu
pour vous dire que
effectivement nous nous inscrivons
depuis le rapport du du coi et depuis
les annonces de la première ministre
dans un contexte qui est
assez structurellement différent du
contexte qui préexister avec le contrat
de performance actuelle il y a une
ambition pour le ferroviaire qui s'est
matérialisée autour du rapport du coi et
autour des annonces de la première
ministre qui nous appartient maintenant
de maintenant de traduire en objective
de régénération du réseau alors d'abord
sur le sur le premier sur le premier
sujet un milliard d'euros en 2027 ça
veut pas dire qu'on fait rien jusqu'en
2027 et qu'on fait et qu'on fait plus un
milliard d'euros en 2027 d'abord parce
qu'industriellement serait pas le faire
donc ce sera des montées progressives
des investissements en
2024 en 2025 en 2026 pour être en 2027 à
un niveau d'investissement un milliard
d'euros plus élevé qu'aujourd'hui et
ensuite tenir dans la durée cet effort
parce que aussi bien le rapport du coi
que les analyses produites par SNCF
réseau montre que le niveau
d'investissement auquel on aboutit avec
ce milliard d'euros complémentaire c'est
un niveau d'investissement qui a un
niveau récurrent si on veut avoir un
réseau performant et donc il faudra
tenir ce niveau d'investissement de
l'ordre de
entre 3,9 et 4 milliards d'euros dans la
durée ensuite pour que le réseau ne
réentâme pas un cycle de vieillissement
et de dégradation de sa de sa
performance mais donc on sera bien dans
une montée en charge progressive des
investissements parce qu'il va falloir
qu'on passe des contrats avec les
industriels avec les entreprises de
travaux qu'on fasse les études
nécessaires pour réussir cette cette
montée cette montée en charge
alors s'agissant de la modernisation
effectivement aujourd'hui nous sommes en
retard sur la commande centralisée du
réseau par rapport aux voisins européens
et sur le rTMS si nous ne sommes pas en
retard en kilomètres nous sommes en
retard en programmation d'investissement
nous ne sommes pas en retard en
kilomètres parce que nous avons mis en
service dans les années 2010 des lignes
à grande vitesse qui sont toutes
équipées de rTMS pour les prolongations
parce que nous sommes aujourd'hui en
train d'équiper la ligne Paris-Lyon en
ERTMS que nous avons un projet très
important entre Marseille et Vintimille
d'équipements en ERTMS donc pour les il
y a des projets mais ensuite on a un
plan de déploiement qui est moins
ambitieux que celui enfin qui était
moins ambitieux que celui de nos voisins
européens avec l'effort d'investissement
de modernisation qu'il a aussi va aller
en croissant pour atteindre 500 millions
d'euros en 2027 il nous appartient de
construire maintenant quel sera le
rythme de déploiement de le RTS et quel
le rythme de déploiement de la commande
centralisée du réseau donc on va
accélérer par rapport à la date de 2070
je sais pas encore vous dire aujourd'hui
comment à quelle date on aboutira au
lieu de 2070 mais ce calendrier sera
accéléré et de même pour le rTMS alors
que nous nous acheminions vers un retard
par rapport aux échéances européennes de
2030 et 2050 importants nous allons
définir un plan de déploiement plus
ambitieux pour nous inscrire dans la
dynamique européenne de déploiement de
RTS donc j'ai pas encore aujourd'hui les
des dates à vous donner par rapport à
ces objectifs de kilomètres de rTMS
déployés mais les moyens qui sont qui
vont nous être alloués vont nous
permettre de construire ce programme et
naturellement ensuite de le communiquer
à l'ensemble des des parties prenantes
et je serais ravi de revenir devant vous
quand quand ce travail là aura été aura
été conduit
alors s'agissant du du
sujet du financement de de l'ensemble de
ces de ces moyens de ces projets pardon
aujourd'hui on a un financement qui
repose beaucoup sur les péages et on
sait que on a un niveau de pH qui par
rapport à d'autres pays européens est
élevé
d'autant plus que nous avons un si on
fonctionne par cycle tarifaire on est
dans un cycle aujourd'hui
2021-2022-2023 et on va ensuite être
dans un cycle de trois ans 2024 2025
2026 qui vient d'être approuvé par
l'autorité de régulation des transports
et qui comporte des augmentations fortes
de pH pour couvrir les effets de
l'inflation puisqu'on était sur des
péages qui jusqu'à présent augmenter de
cette année
2,3% ce qui était les rythmes
d'inflation qu'on connaissait auparavant
sauf que en 2022 et en 2023 on connaît
des rythmes d'inflation qui sont plutôt
de l'ordre de 6% et qui dans les travaux
publics sont encore plus élevés et donc
on aura dans les années 2024 2025-2026
des augmentations de péage importantes
toutes choses égales par ailleurs pour
couvrir les les enjeux de l'inflation et
pour respecter les objectifs du pacte
ferroviaire donc la capacité à augmenter
encore CPH elle est restreinte elle est
peut-être pas nulle ça ça il faudra
l'analyser mais en tout cas elle est
restreinte et elle n'est certainement
pas à la hauteur de l'ensemble des
ambitions qui ont été décrites ici donc
il faudra des financements qui ne
reposent pas que sur les pH ferroviaires
sans ça on ne pourra pas financer un
milliard d'euros de régénération
complémentaires et 500 millions d'euros
de modernisation donc la première
ministre a tracé un certain nombre de
pistes auprès des collectivités de
l'Europe de l'état du groupe SNCF
puisque vous savez qu'il y a une partie
de notre financement qui provient d'un
fonds de concours versé par le groupe
SNCF fond de concours lui-même alimenter
qui correspond en fait aux dividendes du
groupe SNCF alimenté par SNCF voyageurs
par Geodis par Keolis par l'ensemble des
autres entités du groupe SNCF et elle a
aussi évoqué d'autres sources de
financement sur d'autres modes de
transport par exemple ce travail là de
définition du financement il est
largement entre les mains du
gouvernement SNCF réseau comme les
autres entités du groupe SNCF ils
contribueront à la réflexion mais la
décision finale qui doit se dessiner
dans les prochains mois elle sera portée
par le pas par le gouvernement alors si
j'en viens au déploiement des RER
métropolitains qui faisaient partie de
vos questions et des questions du
président et du rôle de la Société du
Grand Paris en la matière alors d'abord
sur les RER métropolitains pour dire et
ça a été dit par le président que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel SNCF réseau
travaille depuis longtemps
la notion de ne ferroviaire c'est
quelque chose qui est porté par SNCF
réseau voire même avant par Réseau ferré
de France depuis de longues années
comment on travaille dans les nœuds
ferroviaires ont désaturne les deux
ferroviaires on rend les nœuds
ferroviaires plus fluides pour de
développer le trafic parce qu'on a la
conviction que le train est un mode qui
permet sur des distances de 30 km 50 km
autour des métropoles de à de nombreuses
personnes de se déplacer et qui peut
être une alternative à la congestion des
métropoles et donc être bénéfique à la
fois à l'accessibilité et bénéfique à
l'environnement et à la décarbonation
donc c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
travaille depuis longtemps c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on a remis un rapport
au gouvernement en 2020 en application
de la loi d'orientation sur les mobilité
et qui a préfiguré ce que sont
aujourd'hui les RER métropolitains donc
la SNCF réseau reste pleinement impliqué
d'ailleurs la première ministre a bien
cité la Société du Grand Paris aux côtés
de SNCF réseau sur ce sujet des RER
métropolites pour le reste
l'apport de la Société du Grand Paris je
vous ai dit on a déjà un milliard
d'euros de régénération en plus à gérer
500 millions d'euros de modernisation en
plus à gérer un certain nombre de
projets de ligne modèles qui sont
aujourd'hui sur la table et sur lequel
on a une demande forte des acteurs de
permettre leur développement les projets
de contrats les contrats de projets
états région qui porte de nombreux
projets notamment sur les plus petites
lignes du territoire SNCF réseau a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de travail dans les
années à venir et c'est déjà un défi
industriel d'être au rendez-vous donc
avoir l'apport de la Société du Grand
Paris qui regroupe 1000 ingénieurs
compétents efficace qui ont montré qu'on
fait leurs preuves sur le territoire
parisien nous on voit ça d'un bon œil on
a fixé un certain nombre de règles du
jeu entre la Société du Grand Paris et
nous de manière à ce qu'on se marge pas
sur les pieds moi je suis rentré à RFF à
une époque où la situation entre RFF et
SNCF infrastructure était pour le moins
tendu et donc la guéguerre entre des
établissements publics je sais à quel
point ça peut être destructeur
perturbant peu efficace pour les
interlocuteurs pour les collectivités
pour les parties prenantes donc avec la
Société du Grand Paris notre volonté
c'est de ne pas retomber dans un schéma
comme ça donc de bien avoir défini des
règles du jeu avant de commencer les
projets il y a déjà des règles du jeu
qui sont assez claires la Société du
Grand Paris ne réclame pas de faire des
travaux sur le réseau qui est exploité
parce que quand on fait des travaux la
nuit et que le matin on doit rendre les
voix au circulation c'est mieux que ce
soit la même entité qui fasse les
travaux et qui est la responsabilité de
rendre les voix aux circulations je
pense que ça rassurea tout le monde
qu'on soit clair sur ce sujet là et en
tout cas pour moi ça aurait été une
ligne rouge mais là dessus on est tombé
tout de suite d'accord avec la Société
du Grand Paris il y a pas de sujet sur
ce sujet
sur les infrastructures nouvelles en
revanche on a l'habitude de faire les
infrastructures nouvelles dans des modes
de réalisation divers et variés on a su
construire des lignes à grande vitesse
avec des partenaires privés on a su
construire des infrastructures nouvelles
et là-dessus la Société du Grand Paris
peut tout à fait construire des
infrastructures nouvelles pour ensuite
les reverser au réseau ferrés national
et à la gestion de SNCF réseau donc là
dessus on est assez à l'aise et
honnêtement les lignes rouges des uns et
des autres sont aujourd'hui tout à fait
respectés et en bonne entente avec mon
collègue Jean-François Jean-François
monte et dans les phases d'études je
pense qu'on peut dans les phases amont
avant de commencer ces travaux je pense
qu'on peut chacun pour notre part
apporter des choses intéressantes et
importantes
j'essaye peut-être d'accélérer sur le
sur le sur le fret
sur le fret naturellement le fret
bénéficiera des investissements dans la
régénération et dans la modernisation du
réseau indépendamment des
investissements spécifiques aux fraises
sur lequel je vais revenir quand on
refait le réseau principal le fret il
roule d'abord sur le réseau principal
quand on modernise le réseau principal
et qu'on peut faire par exemple passer
plus de trains sur une même voie parce
qu'on a déployé ERTMS ça bénéficie au
train de voyageurs mais ça bénéficie
aussi au train de frais quand on déploie
erpms sur un corridor ça permet aux
entreprises de Fred d'avoir le même si
un système de signalisation en Belgique
au Luxembourg en Allemagne en France en
Suisse et donc d'avoir des économies de
coûts et de bénéficier de ces
déploiements donc les les projets de
régénération et de modernisation
bénéficient aux entreprises de frais et
puis il y a un certain nombre
d'investissements spécifiques au frais
qui par ailleurs sont déployés je pense
aux investissements sur les voies de
service je pense aux investissements sur
les grands triages Miramas voix puis
ciblin le Bourget qui sont essentiels au
maintien d'un trafic frais sur lequel
dans le cadre du plan de relance lié à
la crise sanitaire nous avons investi
grâce aux financement apporté par l'État
et au financement apporté par les
collectivités et dans lequel nous
souhaitons continuer à investir dans les
années qui viennent ce sera aussi un des
objets des discussions à venir dans le
cadre des contrats de projet état région
enfin et pour finir s'agissant de la
l'indépendance de SNCF réseau
pour ma part ça fait bientôt 11 ans que
je travaille à Réseau ferré de France
puis à SNCF réseau j'ai vu le marché
s'ouvrir le marché de fret aujourd'hui
et complètement ouvert par exemple et
quand les entreprises de Fred se
plaignent de SNCF réseau c'est pas de
l'indépendance de la SNCF réseau c'est
du manque de performance sur un certain
nombre d'aspects de SNCF réseau alors on
s'emploie à résoudre ces problèmes là
mais dans l'ouverture du marché de fret
la question de l'indépendance de la SNCF
réseau bien qu'on se fasse partie du
groupe SNCF et ça a été la volonté du
législateur ne s'évaporer et je pense
que dans les marchés l'ouverture des
marchés voyageurs que ce soit sur le
marché conventionné avec déjà un certain
nombre de régions qui ont attribué des
lots et par exemple pour la région sud
vous connaissez bien monsieur avec un
lot attribué à un opérateur qui n'est
pas la SNCF les choses se passent
aujourd'hui de manière très correcte et
le rôle de SNCF réseau n'est remis en
cause par aucun des opérateurs et de la
même manière nous avons aujourd'hui sur
la ligne à grande vitesse parions qui
est sans doute la ligne la plus
stratégique du réseau ferré national en
termes de création de de valeur nous
avons aujourd'hui un opérateur français
un opérateur italien nous aurons demain
un opérateur espagnol et les choses là
aussi se passent bien bien que SNCF
réseau soit au sein du groupe
du groupe SNCF donc voilà moi j'ai pas
d'état d'âme et engager une nouvelle
réforme de gouvernance alors qu'on a des
défis industriels majeurs à relever me
semblerait
à contretemps
on va essayer de d'accélérer un petit
peu parce que sinon
alors je vais donner la parole à Madame
Perrault
merci Président Monsieur Chabanel je
vais vous parler de Fred justement et si
vous avez dit que les travaux vont
bénéficier au frais cet été il y a des
groupes qui vont quand même souffrir
terriblement effectivement des travaux
importants ont été annoncés dans le
secteur de Nevers le banlie mettant dans
la quasi incapacité de charger des
trains au départ à azambouy et du silo
accéléréal de Guérini durant la période
de Moisson à venir il ne sera possible
de charger qu'un seul train par semaine
alors que le besoin sur cette période
est de 4 trains hebdomadaires un minima
pour le groupe soufflet agriculture et
trois trains pour accélérer
certes vos équipes sont à l'écoute mais
ce groupe appel de ses vœux à un
dialogue encore plus franc et sincère
lui permettant d'anticiper les
perturbations liées aux travaux afin
d'offrir une meilleure qualité de
service aux différents utilisateurs et
co-financer des lignes capillaires
SNCF réseau a toujours pu compter sur
les groupes in vivo et Axel real pour le
soutenir dans ces opérations de
régénération des lignes capillaires en
participant financièrement en tant que
chargeur le groupe soufflet InVivo reste
à votre écoute monsieur Chabanel pour
trouver ensemble des solutions
permettant de réaliser des objectifs au
service de la transition de
l'agriculture française j'associe à
cette question ma collègue Nadia solo
good de la Nièvre qui a déjà écrit
plusieurs fois
merci
j'ai donné la parole à Pascal Martin qui
a une question de Denis Saint-Pée je
crois oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je me fais le port de
parole ce matin de notre collègue Denise
Saint-Pé qui est sénatrice des
Pyrénées-Atlantiques et qui n'a pas pu
être à nos côtés qui m'a demandé de vous
poser cette question monsieur le
Président
l'augmentation de la demande de mobilité
entre les bassins de vie de Bayonne Dax
orthèses lac Mourenx et pot en
Pyrénées-Atlantiques et Lourdes Tarbes
en Hautes-Pyrénées et très sensible
aussi l'offre ferroviaire TGV Intercité
TER doit être accrue avec le RER
pyrénéen pardon bigor Béar Pays Basque
ce serait une réponse cohérente pour le
train du quotidien
accroître les performances tentant
vitesse en sécurité quand régularité
qu'en confort et instauré un cadencement
avec plus de trains aux heures de pointe
cela demande des travaux dont certains
sont urgents sur une ligne historique
qui a du potentiel un million
d'habitants ayant un besoin de se
déplacer au quotidien aussi monsieur le
Président projetez-vous chez SNCF réseau
d'améliorer le réseau existant du
Sud-Aquitaine Bayonne Dax orthèspo et de
la Bigorre lourde Tarbes et si oui en
quelle condition je vous remercie par
avance de vos réponses merci cher
collègue je vais donner la parole à
Madame Nicole Bonnefoy
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président de SF
SNCF réseau moi je souhaite appeler
votre attention sur la petite ligne de
118 km qui relie les villes d'Angoulême
et Limoges depuis mars 2018 cette ligne
est fermée en raison de défaut
d'entretien constaté par SNCF réseau
l'ensemble des élus des territoires
concernés sont mobilisés pour maintenir
cette lésion ferroviaire pour des
raisons écologiques sociales et
économique pour la desserte du quotidien
et pour le lien bien évidemment avec la
LGV à Angoulême et donc l'accès sur la
façade atlantique depuis Limoges courant
2021 une convention de performance a été
signée entre SNCF réseau et la région
nouvelle-aquitaine en complément d'une
convention de 1,6 milliards avec l'État
pour les 21 petites lignes que compte la
nouvelle Aquitaine cette
contractualisation devait notamment
permettre d'associer la région à la
stratégie sur les projets co-financés
espérons que l'issue des négociations
des prochains CPER apportera les
financements attendus pour cette ligne
monsieur le Président nous attendons
encore les conclusions de l'étude sous
la maîtrise d'ouvrage de SNCF réseau
dont l'objectif était de préciser les
conditions techniques et financières de
réalisation d'une régénération de la
ligne évaluée à plus de 100 millions
d'euros elle devrait nous être
communiquée dans les prochains jours
pourriez-vous profiter de cette audition
pour nous donner la primeur des
conclusions de cette étude qui est très
importante pour la Charente et pour la
Haute-Vienne vous comprendrez qu'après
presque 5 ans d'attente les habitants
méritent d'être informés car ils ne
peuvent comprendre que l'on soit capable
d'une main de réduire l'espace-temps
entre Bordeaux et Paris et de l'autre
d'orchestrer l'abandon d'une ligne
locale et donc laver les territoires
c'est une question qui relève de
l'égalité des territoires par ailleurs
j'ai encore deux autres questions dans
le cas de l'ouverture du marché à
l'instar de l'arrivée de nouveaux
opérateurs comme l'entreprise
ferroviaire le train dont le siège est
dans mon département où la Reims ou
trinitalia comment analysez-vous les
conditions de développement de services
avez-vous identifié les points de
vigilance majeurs qui pourraient freiner
le développement de nouveaux services
voyageurs une autre question vous
connaissez sans doute les débats sur le
financement du GPSO je pense que les
collègues pourront y revenir y compris
des réactions des territoires charentés
par exemple qui refuse d'y contribuer à
cet égard pourriez-vous nous préciser
dans quelle mesure la contribution de
nouveaux opérateurs étaient prises en
compte dans les recettes de cette future
infrastructure et un petit dernier sur
le fret on est d'accord il faut
développer le frais de ferroviaire j'ai
un exemple dans mon département de la
gare fret de Cognac qui a été inauguré à
grande pompe il y a quelques années et
qui ne fonctionne absolument pas les
entreprises du cognac les maisons du
cognac préférant prendre la route ce qui
est absolument inacceptable
son rapport et donc la nécessité que
nous avons de développer le frais de
ferroviaire une gare qui existe et qui
ne fonctionne pas merci pour vos
réponses merci chers collègues la parole
est à Jean-Michel Houlgate merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président le contrat de performance
entre l'État et la SNCF réseau donc
2021-2030 dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
qui est d'ailleurs très critiqué prévoit
néanmoins pour le trafic des lignes de
desserte fines du territoire que d'une
part un premier groupe de 14 lignes et
pour continuer l'annuaire des chemins de
fer parmi ces lignes puisque je suis élu
de la mort je citerai le Lison Cherbourg
mais aussi le renne Saint-Malo et le
cantou que ce réseau serait intégré aux
réseaux structurant au 1er janvier 2024
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce que ça va concrètement ce que cela va
apporter deuxièmement toujours dans dans
le cas de ce contrat de performance il
est il est prévu que les lignes à
vocation régionales ou interrégionales
des conventions doivent être signés
entre SNCF réseau et les régions qui le
afin de définir les objectifs et les
engagements réciproques des parties en
matière de qualité de service rendu à
l'usagés de même en application de la
loi l'homme des transferts de missions
de ligne de dessert fines peuvent être
effectués où en est-on à l'heure
actuelle de ces transferts et puis enfin
dernière question il est mentionné que
SNCF réseau poursuivra ses efforts en
matière de solution innovantes et peu
coûteuse et qui sont elles adaptées aux
caractéristiques des lignes les moins
circuler ou ayant vocation à être
remises en service c'est la réflexion
donc ce qu'on appelle autour du train
léger pouvez-vous nous faire part des
avancements sur ces solutions innovantes
merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Ancher le privil merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de SNCF
réseau oui il y a un fantastique défi et
moi je vous parle en tant que sénatrice
du Lot d'un département où nous sommes
de plus en plus éloignés de Paris vous
savez que nous sommes des servis par la
ligne Paul parieur Orléans Limoges
Toulouse et donc j'aurai des questions
déjà à ce sujet là parce que nous
pouvons nous estimer en quelque sorte
délaissés voir les oublier du
ferroviaire et pour vous inciter à mieux
équilibrer la planification afin
d'éviter des ruptures totales de
circulation il est important que les
travaux de régénération parce que là il
suffit il s'agit de régénération se
poursuivent en conformité avec le schéma
directeur de la ligne POLT et notamment
pour ce qui concernement département
entre Brive Cahors et Montauban puisque
j'avais compris que nous étions une
partie de la ligne qui était déclassée
alors vous me direz ce que voilà ce
qu'il en est et notamment sur le
renouvellement des poteaux caténaires
qui n'ont pas eu d'entretien depuis 40
ans des deux voies principales rails et
ballast même chose sinon une imitation
de vitesse un augmentation du temps de
parcours qui sont déjà très peu
performants nous sommes tout de même à
5h30 pour Cahors Paris et avec des
déplacements bien supérieurs à ceux au
temps du Capitole donc voilà j'ai une
autre question concernant ce que vous
avez mentionné tout à l'heure c'est à
dire le nouveau partenariat avec France
Nature Environnement vous avez mentionné
la fin du glyphosate de l'économie
circulaire est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus et enfin dernière petite
question sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence et notamment qu'elle regarde
vous portez sur la société rydcoop qui
est basée dans mon département
alors je vais donner la parole à encore
à deux intervenants Monsieur Louis Jean
de nicolaïpuy Jacques Ferny et puis
après vous répondrez Louis-Jean et
Nicolay oui merci monsieur le Président
comment on est dans la liste des courses
je vais faire la mienne aussi
monsieur le Président je la ligne à
Lançon le manteau a été récemment rénové
ce que vous considérez ce qu'on peut
considérer qu'aujourd'hui elle est
parfaitement
suffisamment rénovée réorganisée haute
pour permettre un accroissement des
trains et notamment des trains
marchandises il y avait eu 40 millions
d'euros qui avait été prévus est-ce que
ceci a été
engagé et puis si oui et surtout la
partie sud est-ce que il y a aussi les
travaux à faire pour garantir à terme
une bonne médiation de de cette ligne le
deuxième point qui vous concerne
peut-être pas que c'était plutôt SNCF
infrastructure mais de dire c'est que
vous savez que nous rentrons dans les
ânes les zones d'articulation honnête et
que par conséquent il serait peut-être
intéressant que
SNCF réseau et SN CF infrastructure
puisque communiquer assez rapidement sur
les délaissés qui pourraient être pris
par les collectivités pour permettre une
meilleure utilisation de céder c'est
soit en matière de transformation
énergétique haute comme des panneaux
photovoltaïques qui a été le carnage
notamment ou soit dans pour permettre
une artisation c'est des terres
complètement
merci chers collègues la parole est à
chaque Fanny oui merci monsieur le
Président je suis le président si
effectivement le rapport du coi avec le
discours de la première ministre qui a
suivi si
[Musique]
les promesses sont tenues et si les
démarches annoncées sont engagées c'est
apparemment effectivement c'est le rail
qui va être la priorité des priorités
c'est clair
régénération modernisation du fer on a
parlé de des du gros retard
ERTMS et CCR dans au regard du contexte
européen il y a l'accélération des
projets donc vous en avez évoqué des
réseaux Express ou des services express
métropolitains
là-dessus moi je vois l'expérience c'est
ça fait déjà trois mois que c'est
l'ancien Strasbourg du du raté du
démarrage de Strasbourg et c'est plus
que le raté du démarrage il a été
annoncé hier ou avant-hier car lors
qu'on aurait dû être à 810 trains
supplémentaires hebdomadaires
ils espèrent arriver début juin à 640
alors c'est le problème essentiellement
de SNCF voyageurs mais on a aussi des
problèmes de capacité de fluidité de
souplesse du réseau il y a véritablement
un
savoir-faire une organisation et une
modernisation du réseau qui qui assure
le qui peut assurer effectivement le
fonctionnement de de ces réseaux Express
métropolitain
alors deux questions sur sur ces choix
non c'est très très fort
d'investissement dans le ferroviaire
déjà les moyens pour y parvenir du point
du financier donc vous l'avez évoqué
c'est clair que le contrat de
performance il est caduque surtout que
c'est un contrat de permanence ça a été
dit qu'il repose essentiellement sur les
péages je crois d'ailleurs qu'hier ou
avant-hier la RT a rejeté les tarifs
2024 26 qui proposait par SNCF réseau
pour les prestations régulières
terminaux de marchandises voies de
service et tarifs rede stationnement en
gare en estimant si bien compris qu'il y
avait les erreurs des certitudes des
hausses insuffisamment justifiées donc
en demandant de revoir la copie ma
question aussi c'est les pas simplement
les moyens financiers mais les moyens en
capacité de travaux pour y parvenir
votre prédécesseur nous parlait d'une
capacité aujourd'hui de 300 millions à
peu près d'euros de travaux par an
avec le milliard et demi supplémentaires
au bout du quinquennat si j'ai bien
compris ça veut dire une capacité de
travaux pas simplement d'organisation
matérielle mais aussi en ressources
humaines il y a tout un volet de
formation renforcée et ma deuxième
question c'est sur la problématique
alors qui est nouvelle inattendue pour
certains je sais plus qui disait qui
aurait pu prévoir le réchauffement
climatique bon c'est annoncé quand même
depuis longtemps mais c'est vrai que
notre réseau ferré est particulièrement
vulnérable alors on pense tous à la
déformation des rails mais il y a la
question du réseau électrique les câbles
électriques iques qui se distendent avec
les systèmes de sécurité qui estiment
que c'est coupé alors que ça l'est pas
c'est quand même je crois que vous êtes
le deuxième consommateur électricité le
réseau ferré et puis aussi à la question
de comment voyager de façon vivable pour
les voyageurs quand on a des canicules à
35 45 degrés donc quelle réponse à cette
vulnérabilité qui a été pointée dans le
rapport du coi et quel plan pourrit
remédier
merci je vous propose de répondre à mes
collègues merci Monsieur le Directeur
alors
c'était madame Pérou la première
oui alors s'agissant des des du travail
avec les chargeurs céréaliers j'ai eu
l'occasion à l'occasion du salon
d'agriculture de rencontrer les acteurs
de inter céréales puisque effectivement
c'est une préoccupation importante pour
SNCF réseau pour le développement du
frais de ferroviaire de de s'assurer que
le frais de céréalier ce continue à se
développer la France est un pays
exportateur le les ports de Rouen de La
Rochelle de Dunkerque sont parmi les
premiers ports en Europe pour le port de
Rouen le premier port en Europe
de d'export de d'export de céréales et
et donc il faut qu'on puisse aller
jusqu'au silo et traiter les différentes
campagnes céréalières ensuite on est
confronté sur ces lignes qui sont
souvent très anciennes et sur lequel il
y a pas eu de travaux de fait de
puissance 120 ans 130 ans on est qu'on
est confronté à ça c'est des lignes sur
souvent de 1900 à des enjeux de comment
on minimise les coûts et c'est vrai que
pour minimiser les coûts la meilleure
méthode c'est de fermer la ligne de
faire les travaux et de la rouvrir après
et comment on maintient les circulations
donc on cherche des équilibres sur le
sur la situation de Nevers je serai pas
vous répondre mais on va re-regarder
naturellement ce sujet là on a réussi à
faire passer un train par semaine est-ce
qu'on peut en faire passer plus sans
abaisser drastiquement la performance
des travaux et donc étaler les chantiers
et faire des chantiers qui coûtent plus
cher sachant que ces chantiers ils sont
financés par les chargeurs céréaliers
par les collectivités locales et par
l'État et donc il faut aussi que les
financeurs voilà si on veut avoir des
travaux qui sont qui laissent passer
tous les trains ce sera des travaux plus
chers et les plans de financement seront
plus compliqué à monter donc c'est cet
équilibre là qu'il faut qu'on construise
collectivement avec les l'ensemble des
acteurs du tour de table mais je
comprends bien la préoccupation et pour
SNCF réseau c'est un enjeu important et
on travaille avec les groupes céréaliers
à quels sont les silos prioritaires à
préserver dans dans
ce paysage là
qui est important et on a des
investissements sur les ce qu'on appelle
les capillaires fret ces petites lignes
qui desservent les silos céréaliers
importants à la fois en région
Centre-Val de Loire et en région Grand
Est puis qui sont les deux régions
principales pour pour ce sujet là alors
ensuite j'avais la question de Monsieur
Martin sur sur la le bigor Béarn shalos
donc sur ce territoire là on a lancé des
études de modernisation effectivement
avec l'État et la région
nouvelle-aquitaine sur lesquelles on a
défini différents scénarios
il va il va maintenant appartenir à
l'état à la région dans le cadre du
contrat de projet est à région de
définir dans ces scénarios qui qui
qui portent des ambitions différentes et
mais aussi des coûts différents plus
l'ambition et autres plus les coûts sont
élevés de définir le scénario retenu
pour le développement du trafic dans
cette zone parallèlement SNCF réseau sur
ces investissements propres travaille à
la modernisation dans cette zone on a
investi plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros je me rappelle notamment d'un
chantier où on a refait entièrement la
voix entre articles et pots on a on est
en train de moderniser dans ce secteur
là la caténaire alors pour ceux qui
connaissent c'est une caténaire en ogive
la caténaire midi qui date des années 30
du siècle précédent et donc il est temps
de refaire et de et de moderniser et
donc là il y a des investissements
importants qui sont portés par SNCF
réseau lui-même dans le cadre de la
régénération du réseau et qui vont
pouvoir être accélérés dans le cadre du
milliard d'euros complémentaire qu'on
ambitionne à l'horizon
2027 je crois qu'ensuite c'était madame
Bonnefoy si je ne me trompe pas dans le
dans mes fiches alors s'agissant la
ligne entre Angoulême et Limoges
effectivement elle est elle est fermée
même si la desserte proche de Limoges
reste ouverte notamment pour les
scolaires mais pour la pour la ligne
elle-même elle est fermée et ça
réouverture pour intervenir dans le
cadre des discussions CPER et de du 13
ambitieux plan pour les lignes de
dessert fin du territoire qui est porté
par la région par la région nouvelle
Aquitaine ça me donne l'occasion
peut-être et ça répondra à plusieurs
questions de dire quelques mots sur les
sur les lignes de dessert fines du
territoire en général sur les lignes de
dessert fin du territoire en général
d'abord il y a les 14 lignes qui
réintègrent le réseau structurant pour
ces lignes là SNCF réseau n'ira plus
chercher s'agissant de leur régénération
si on parle de développement c'est
différent mais s'agissant de leur
régénération n'ira plus chercher de
co-financement après 2024 auprès de
l'État et des régions ça s'inscrira dans
le plan de régénération du réseau du
réseau structurant financé par SNCF
réseau
s'il y a des projets au-delà de la
régénération de développement là on
rentrera dans la mécanique classique des
CPR ensuite sur les autres lignes de
desserte film du territoire elle
s'inscrivent dans le cadre des CPER avec
des ambitions qui sont j'allais dire à
la main des collectivités régionales on
a certaines collectivités qui sont
parties sur des plans très ambitieux
structurés pour lequel nous on a monté
des équipes dédiées de type ce qu'on
appelle Plan Rail à la fois d'ingénierie
et de travaux pour porter dans la durée
je pense par exemple la région
occitanique il y a des ou la région
nouvelle Aquitaine qui ont développé des
plans importants et sur lequel on met
des moyens dédiés dans d'autres régions
on est plutôt sur des projets classiques
de CPER ou au cas par cas sur une ligne
donnée on refait on refait la ligne et
on en a refait de nombreuses au cours
des dernières années et puis enfin il y
a un certain nombre de régions qui ont
engagé en application de l'article 172
de la loi l'homme des processus de trans
de gestion c'est le cas notamment en
région Grand Est où il y a une volonté
d'un transfert de gestion de l'ensemble
des lignes de desserts fines du
territoire sur lequel on travaille main
dans la main avec la région pour
accompagner ces mécanismes de transfert
c'est aussi le cas en région Occitanie
sur deux lignes fermées qui sont mon
résolution et à l'sbc et au conseil
d'administration de SNCF réseau du mois
de février le conseil a voté le
transfert de la ligne mon résolution qui
est le premier ligne sur laquelle le
transfert de région est de gestion
pardon à la région et aujourd'hui
complètement engagée donc j'allais dire
sur les lignes de dessert de fines du
territoire SNCF réseau se met au service
de la volonté des collectivités sauf
pour les 14 lignes qu'il a réintégré sur
lequel là il est pleinement responsable
et il doit assurer la performance de ce
réseau comme du reste du réseau
structurant
alors s'agissant pour revenir aux
questions de Madame Bonnefoy s'agissant
de l'ouverture du marché et des
conditions de succès je pense que du
point de vue du réseau il y a plusieurs
conditions de succès d'abord c'est
d'organiser les circulations dans un
marché plus ouvert de manière à ce que
chacun trouve son sillon sur les voies
chacun trouve sa place donc dans un
certain nombre de cas on quand on est
sur l'ouverture du marché conventionné
ça nécessite un travail étroit avec les
autorités organisatrices donc avec les
régions et quand on est sur le marché
librement organisé les initiatives du
type le train raikoop etc dans ce cas-là
il nous appartient de prévoir dans les
dans les plans d'organisation des
sillons dans les trames de sillons
décision qui puissent être revendiquées
par ces nouveaux par ces nouveaux
acteurs donc ça c'est sur le volet
organisation des sillons il y a ensuite
un deuxième défi qui est important c'est
comment on organise l'espace ferroviaire
notamment autour des principaux noeuds
parce que tous ces secteur là ils
veulent pouvoir remiser leurs trains
donc avoir des voix pour remiser leurs
trains qui sont pas les mêmes voies que
l'opérateur historique ils veulent
généralement en plus avoir un centre
d'entretien de leur train qui soit pas
nécessairement celui de l'opérateur
historique même si la SNCF a des
obligations d'accueillir dans ces
centres d'entretien du des trains
incertains les autres opérateurs mais
généralement ils préfèrent avoir leur
propre centre d'entretien de leur train
donc ça nécessite pour SNCF réseau
d'organiser l'espace et de trouver
parfois des terrains qui sont pas qui
sont pas nécessairement disponibles donc
on a on a ces sujets là qui sont des
sujets clés dans la réussite de
l'ouverture à la concurrence et sur
lequel nos équipes sont particulièrement
impliquées je pense que c'est des sujets
qui dont on va au fur et à mesure de
cette ouverture découvrir encore mieux
toute l'importance s'agissant du
financement du GPSO
il y a aujourd'hui du côté des
collectivités une société de financement
et un dialogue entre l'État et les
collectivités pour le montage de
financement intégrant naturellement les
perspectives de trafic de la ligne mais
voilà moi je n'ai pas aujourd'hui
l'avancement final du financement du GPS
mais naturellement on pourra vous vous
donner les éléments alors ensuite
j'avais
la garde de Fred de Cognac alors
alors tout à fait mais mais à un moment
la balle n'est pas que dans le camp de
SNCF réseau elle est dans le camp d'un
côté des chargeurs c'est à dire des
entreprises productrices de Cognac en
l'occurrence et dans l'autre des
entreprises ferroviaires à même de leur
rendre un service notamment on sait
qu'il y a un très fort flux d'export via
le port du Havre premier port
exportateur cette fois-ci de 20 et
spiritueux en France et peut-être et
sans doute en Europe là aussi et donc il
y a un fort flux de Cognac vers Le Havre
mais là mais mais là mais là il faut il
faut que il faut que les mais ça peut
pas être SNCF réseau il doit mettre à
disposition son infrastructures il doit
trouver les sillons pour les trains mais
c'est pas lui qui peut s'immiscer dans
la relation entre les producteurs de
Cognac d'une part et les entreprises
ferroviaires d'autre part pour autant en
lien avec le port du Havre on a une
action de dynamisation des trafics
ferroviaires pour au moins faire
connaître la solution ferroviaire au
chargeur mais mais on peut enfin voilà
on n'a pas de pouvoir de coercition
entre la route et le faire nous notre
enjeu c'est d'offrir la meilleure
prestation possible de circulation sur
le réseau aux entreprises ferroviaires
et aux chargeurs qui seraient intéressés
alors
sur le volet de la commercialisation
parce que ce que nous on fait c'est
qu'on essaye de réunir les acteurs et
notamment en 2023 on va faire des forums
régionaux mettant les chargeurs d'un
côté et les entreprises ferroviaires de
l'autre autour des mêmes tables de
manière à ce que dans un certain nombre
de cas et ils connaissent pas la
solution etc mais le contrat commercial
entre le producteur de Cognac il le
passe bien avec l'entreprise ferroviaire
qui ensuite nous achète ainsi mais mais
le lien commercial il est bien entre le
chargeur et l'entreprise ferroviaire
alors Monsieur Houlgate alors Monsieur
Houlgate donc il y avait sur les sur les
lignes de dessert fin du territoire donc
effectivement Lison Cherbourg Rennes
Saint-Malo et contour sont aujourd'hui
intégrés dans le réseau truc enfin
seront au 1er janvier 2024 intégré dans
le réseau structurant ce qui permet le
la poursuite des trafics sur ces lignes
notamment des trafics de fret avec
le projet d'autoroute ferroviaire entre
Cherbourg et le et le Pays Basque porté
par Britanny Ferris qui empruntera
cet itinéraire entre lisant et Cherbourg
et entre et entre et entre et entre Caen
et Tours et donc là on a on a un réseau
qui aujourd'hui est continuera à être
entretenu par SNCF réseau s'agissant des
conventions avec les les régions sur la
qualité de service effectivement SNCF
réseau a signé des conventions de
performance avec plusieurs régions
notamment la région Normandie la région
sud de la région nouvelle Aquitaine
autour de la qualité de service sur le
sur le sur la région de France je vais
pas toutes les citer sur la qualité de
service sur le réseau avec des des
incitations financières
modestes en montant mais importantes
pour pour se mettre d'accord sur les sur
les objectifs et ensuite travailler à
leur amélioration et on continue à
s'inscrire dans cette dans cette
dynamique là s'agissant des solutions
innovantes sur les lignes de desserts de
films du territoire alors il y a
beaucoup de solutions il y a des
solutions qui peuvent se développer sur
l'infrastructure elle-même je pense par
exemple aux solutions qu'on avait retenu
entre Avranches et dol où on avait mis
moins de traverses sur la voie tout en
l’interdisant au train de fret puisque
avec moins de traverses on peut pas
avoir des trains de fret mais ça avait
permis en mettant moins de traverse
d'avoir des coûts régénération de la
voix beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
importante donc ça ça avait été un
projet qui permettait pour le trafic TER
de faire un projet de régénération moins
cher c'était une solution innovante
ensuite on a des solutions innovantes
qui vont porter sur le matériel roulant
avec beaucoup d'acteurs qui aujourd'hui
se positionnent notamment dans le cadre
des appels à manifestation d'intérêt
porté par l'État dans le cadre des
projets d'investissement d'avenir pour
développer des trains légers voire des
trains très légers
qui doivent permettre d'une part d'avoir
des coûts d'exploitation du train moins
important mais aussi des coûts sur
l'infrastructure qui eux aussi peuvent
être moins importants donc ces projets
ils sont encore en phase de peut-être
pas de recherche mais au moins
d'innovation et de développement des
premiers des premiers prototypes mais ce
sont des pistes intéressantes pour
abaisser les coups sur l'infrastructure
mais aussi les coûts d'exploitation ça
n'exonera pas quand on a des voix qui
ont 80 ou 100 ans de faire des travaux
de faire des travaux sur la voie ça
pourra les rendre moins coûteux
alors ensuite on avait madame Préville
alors sur sur l'axe Paris Orléans
Limoges Limoges Toulouse
donc on naturellement c'est un axe qui
nous tient beaucoup à cœur j'ai été avec
Jean-Pierre farando et Christophe aniché
à Limoges le 3 le 3 mars
la tenue du schéma directeur notamment
en matière de régénération et des 1
milliard 600 millions qui doivent être
mis en place sur la régénération sur cet
axe et un objectif extrêmement fort de
SNCF réseau pour le moment nous sommes
dans les temps et nous veillons à
continuer à être dans les temps et nous
en rendrons contre trimestriellement à
l'occasion de ce comité et l'axe pour
nous il va jusqu'à Toulouse donc il a
inclut bien le lot il y a pas de doute
sur cette partie là on aura d'ailleurs
cette année un chantier industriel de
remplacement des poteaux caténaires qui
ont comme vous le disiez qui date de
après
là juste après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et qui n'ont pas été traités
depuis et on aura l'année prochaine un
chantier de régénération de la voie très
important entre l'albanque écossale donc
on traite bien la partie de la ligne qui
est au sud de Brive voilà il y a pas de
il y a pas de doute il y a pas de doute
de doute là-dessus sur les sujets
environnementaux
donc on a dévoilé d'action autour de la
biodiversité qui est à la fois un enjeu
et une contrainte pour nous parce que
vous savez que le traitement de la
végétation c'est le premier budget au
sein des budgets de maintenance de la
SNCF réseau 12% des budgets de
maintenance de SNCF réseau près de 250
millions d'euros sont consacrés au
traitement de la végétation donc c'est
c'est c'est voilà parce que on doit
traiter les arbres les abords c'est des
sources d'irrégularité ça peut être je
peux même créer des risques et donc on a
ce traitement là c'est un traitement qui
devient aujourd'hui de de plus en plus
compliqué on le sait puisque on peut pas
couper les arbres au printemps passer la
période de nidification c'est compliqué
voilà donc on a moins de produits pour
traiter puisqu'on est sorti du
glyphosate donc c'est un enjeu qui est à
la fois un enjeu économique et
environnemental qu'on doit gérer et qui
est de plus en plus compliqué mais sur
lequel on met des moyens extrêmement
importants aujourd'hui donc l'aspect
biodiversité ensuite on a l'aspect
économie circulaire aujourd'hui on
recycle 50% de ce qu'on enlève quand on
fait des travaux notre objectif c'est
demain de recycler 100%. donc sur le
rail je vous le disais on a des filières
de valorisation du rail y compris en le
refondant en acier pour refaire du rail
sur le sur le sur les traverses on est
en train avec le l'Université de Lille
de travailler à des à des méthodes de
recyclage et sur le ballast
aujourd'hui ont réussi à trier le
ballast pour j'allais dire d'enlever que
les cailloux qu'il faut vraiment enlever
c'est à dire ceux qui sont plus aptes
voir les performances qu'on attend sur
une voie ferrée et les autres les
remettre en voix donc à consommer moins
de matières premières donc voilà
biodiversité économie circulaire et le
troisième enjeu c'est la décarbonation
de nos activités comment on a des engins
de chantier comment on a des véhicules
qui soient le plus décarbonés possible
notamment avec des filières électriques
voire hydrogène et dernier point sur la
société rail COP c'est une société qui
se positionne sur l'ouverture du marché
donc on l'accompagne jusqu'à présent
elle a reporté ses dates ces dates
d'ouverture elles vise maintenant 2024
mais SNCF réseau comme vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des entreprises est en phase
d'accompagnement de Raikov après ça doit
être monsieur de Nicolaï je pense
donc sur la ligne Alençon le manteau
j'en ai dit un mot je
et sur le et sur le zan effectivement
c'est un enjeu c'est un enjeu important
sur le on a à la fois un enjeu dans les
travaux à venir on voit bien que si on
fait une ligne comme GPSO dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure et que on doit
compter dans les quotas des communes en
matière d'artificialisation les effets
d'usane ont réussira pas à faire des
grands projets d'Anvers national donc il
faut qu'on trouve des moyens de décompte
de l'artificealisation liées à des
grands projets d'intérêt national comme
celui-là qui permet de les de les
conduire et d'autre part j'allais dire
de l'autre sens on a effectivement des
laissés ferroviaires qui peuvent être
intéressants pour faire du
photovoltaïque ou pour faire des des
activités
diverses qui rentrent là aussi dans la
réflexion autour du autour du zan donc
on a un vrai enjeu très très structurant
autour du zan du côté de la SNCF réseau
enfin Monsieur Ferny
alors sur
le rTMS c'est la CCR
je pense avoir dit l'essentiel tout à
l'heure voilà il faut vraiment qu'on
s'inscrive dans dans la programmation de
ces moyens sur les services express qui
ont été polyins et et sur Strasbourg
pour pour regarder les choses en face le
démarrage du du REM de Strasbourg n'a
pas été satisfaisant c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire SNCF réseau il y a sa
part sans doute dans le fait de ne pas
avoir été suffisamment le gardien de ce
qu'il est possible de faire c'est à dire
de ne pas avoir dit faire 800 une
augmentation de 800 trains d'un coup
c'est sans doute trop ambitieux
prévoyons des marges d'emblée et c'est
vrai que SNCF réseau je le disais tout à
l'heure un rôle d'organisateur des
circulations donc c'est pas tant que
l'infrastructure est pas au rendez-vous
c'est plutôt dans ce rôle d'organisateur
ou n'aurait peut-être dû être plus ferme
mais c'est pas forcément évident dans la
relation avec les partenaires
entreprises ferroviaire en tant que
territoire organisatrice de dire non on
y va pas on y va plus progressivement
ensuite ce qu'on peut se dire si on soit
la bouteille à moitié pleine c'est que
en juillet on fera quand même 640 trains
de plus sur une infrastructure
équivalente ce qui est très intéressant
en terme de dynamique ferroviaire et ce
qui permet de dire que effectivement les
RER métropolitains c'est d'abord pour
regarder comment on fait plus avec les
infrastructures qui existent avant de
construire de nouvelles infrastructures
je pense que là dessus c'est c'est un
vrai enjeu partagé entre les métropoles
des autorités organisatrices et SNCF
réseau de se dire avant d'aller dans des
grands projets pharaoniques qui sont
longs qui coûtent cher etc regardons
quand même mais de manière plus
structurée plus raisonnable que ce qu'on
a fait en jouant en pleinement notre
rôle du côté de SNCF réseau où on n'a
pas été suffisamment au rendez-vous
comment on réussit à mettre plus de
trains sur les infrastructures
existantes s'agissant
des moyens et de la capacité à faire les
travaux effectivement quand on part de
aujourd'hui au but un budget 2000 2023
environ 3 milliards d'euros de travaux
de régénération et qu'on se dit qu'en
2027 il faudra faire 4 milliards et demi
d'euros de travaux de régénération et de
modernisation c'est une augmentation de
50% de notre production industrielle en
milieu contrainte puisqu'on doit gérer
les les dans un dans une dynamique
industrielle qui va nécessiter beaucoup
de ressources humaines chez nous et dans
la filière ferroviaire et je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est c'est un prérequis
à nos ambitions c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'on réussisse à rendre la filière
ferroviaire à SNCF réseau mais dans les
entreprises de travaux dans les
entreprises de signalisation dans les
entreprises d'ingénierie attractive donc
ça ça nous oblige à une réflexion sur
les métiers ça oblige à une réflexion
sur les salaires ça oblige à une
réflexion sur le développement alors on
a la chance d'avoir des des des jeunes
qui rentrent sur le marché du travail
qui sont séduits par le train qui se
disent si je vais travailler dans le
train je participe à une dynamique de
préservation de la planète de mobilité
verte etc etc donc ça c'est un facteur
d'attractivité mais ça peut pas être le
seul facteur d'attractivité et donc si
on veut réussir le défi industriel qui
est devant nous il va falloir qu'on
travaille sur l'attractivité des SNCF
réseau mais de toute la filière
ferroviaire dans les territoires parce
qu'il y a des territoires où il est très
difficile aujourd'hui de recruter il y a
des métiers notamment les métiers
d'électricien où il est extrêmement
difficile de recruter aujourd'hui sur la
résilience au changement climatique
pardon je suis désolé mais il y avait
beaucoup de questions sur la résidence
au changement climatique
d'abord les premiers enjeux c'est des
enjeux d'exploitation comment on fait en
sorte de pas envoyer des trains quand on
a des alertes météo qui sont aujourd'hui
plus fréquentes plus intenses etc donc
c'est d'abord ça le premier enjeu
ensuite comment on assure la résidence
du réseau tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et
notamment le travail sur les
déformations voiles et des formations de
caténaires ça on peut le faire à
infrastructure constante et on a l'année
dernière pas eu beaucoup de déformations
de voix par rapport à nos voisins
européens donc ça c'est plutôt un point
de de satisfaction pour autant on a bien
vu que la circulation était de moins
bonne qualité l'été donc on a encore du
travail à faire et à long terme moi les
deux facteurs d'inquiétude prioritaires
par rapport au changement climatique
c'est tous les équipements électroniques
comment ils réussissent à tenir à des
températures de 50 degrés plutôt que de
40 degrés puisqu'ils sont plutôt conçus
pour des températures de 40 degrés les
équipements électroniques que ce soit
dans les trains ou sur le réseau et
deuxièmement c'est l'évolution des de ce
qu'on appelle les remblais ou des
déblais de tout ce qui est en terre qui
avec les variations les sécheresses etc
notamment sur tout ce qui est argileux
c'est pas propre aux ferroviaire mais
enfin on a beaucoup de remblais beaucoup
de déblay surtout ce qui est argileux
pose des vrais sujets de gestion de ces
de ces de ces infrastructures
merci alors il reste 11 interventions je
vais donner la parole à Monsieur devinez
merci monsieur le Président moi je vais
pas vous poser des questions sur le
noeud ferroviaire lyonnais il y a des
réunions organisées par la préfecture de
la région auquel les parlementaires sont
invités et et les parlementaires y
participent quand elles n'ont pas lieu
le mardi le mercredi moi je voulais
revenir sur deux petites questions
c'est le doublement du mode fret il a
été abordé par des collègues c'est un
objectif qui est inscrit dans la Lomme
qui est inscrit dans la loi climat et
résilience et puis quand vous vivez sur
en périphérie de la métropole lyonnaise
vous le pouvez que souhaiter que cet
objectif rentre dans les fêtes or dans
les fêtes les opérateurs souvent sont
assez unanimes pour dénoncer les goulets
d'entregrement du trafic je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail mais d'où ma
question comment SNCF réseau compte il
réellement donné sa part au fret
deuxième question le réseau ferroviaire
n'est pas directement accessible à
l'ensemble de nos concitoy ens et
concitoyens donc qui a nécessité d'être
connecté à d'autres modes de transport
de transport routier ou transport
partagé ça implique des rupteurs de
charge comment les limiter et permettre
aux réseaux ferroviaires d'être mieux
connecté avec les autres modes
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Bigot
merci monsieur le président
vous aviez signé un rapport intitulé
étoile ferroviaire et service express
métropolitain en 2020 qui a fait date et
qui prévoyait de mettre en place des RER
métropolitains aujourd'hui on sait qu'il
y a 10 sites qui ont été 10 villes
pilotes qui ont été retenues par le
président pourrait-on connaître les
critères retenus parce que au regard des
enjeux de décarbonation je pense qu'il
faudrait élargir et donc votre réponse
est assez attendue sur ce sujet j'aurais
une autre question à vous poser j'ai pu
constater que SNCF réseau expérimenté en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté un dispositif
innovant des faroucheur sonore
automatique pour empêcher le passage
d'animaux sauvages comme les sangliers
sur les voies ferrées c'est un vrai
sujet sur la ligne Angers Paris mais je
pense qu'il y a d'autres lignes aussi
qui sont concernées les retards
occasionnés sont excessifs sans compter
les dégâts matériels engendrés par les
collisions est-ce que vous pensez
généraliser ce dispositif et dans quel
délai je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur marchand
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le Président je vais vous faire
poursuivre votre tour de France vous
faire remonter au nord dans la région
Hauts-de-France qui cultive des
relations un peu particulières avec la
SNCF j'en conviens parfois épidermique
mais bon parfois il faut se féliciter de
certaines avancées je serai pas aussi
sévère que mes collègues Tabarro et
gilets sur le sujet de la commande
centralisée du réseau puisque ça y est
enfin dans la région des Hauts-de-France
après 50 travaux à la mi-mai cette
commande centralisée du réseau sera
opérationnelle ce qui devrait mais pas
que améliorer
l'utilisation et les rotations sur notre
réseau ferroviaire par contre autre
sujet d'interrogations dans les hauts de
France mais qui je pense peut aussi
toucher d'autres régions c'est quid des
lignes qui sont définitivement fermées
puisque nous avons aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire des lignes définitivement
enfermées notamment autour de la
métropole lilloise et la question qui
est posée par les élus c'est pourrait-on
imaginer un jour que SNCF réseau dans sa
grande bonté puis céder à titre gracieux
le foncier de ces lignes qui sont
définitivement fermées pour que les
communes et les territoires qui ont
envie de bâtir des projets de mobilité à
la fois pour les mobilités du quotidien
mais aussi mobilité du touristique
puisse bénéficier de cet atout dans leur
projet merci
merci la parole est à Olivier Jacquin
merci le Président je suis ravi de vous
rencontrer Monsieur le PDG pour
information j'ai militais pour que votre
nomination fasse partie des auditions du
Parlement et je regrette que ça ne soit
pas le cas actuellement je ne poserai
que trois questions monsieur le PDG la
première je vais partir des sceptiques
sur la conversion récente du
gouvernement sur le ferroviaire je suis
interrogatif sur la recherche des
financement pour atteindre les 100
milliards d'euros sur le ferroviaire et
à ce titre notre unanimité en commission
du développement durable contre le
contrat de performance qui était
véritablement insincer se trouve
révélée par la position actuelle du
gouvernement alors vous avez évoqué la
nécessité trouver de des nouveaux
financements et de ne pas reposer
uniquement sur les péages n'est-il pas
l'heure d'écrire
un nouveau contrat de performance sans
attendre l'échéance de celui-ci et
j'insiste fortement sur cette question
vous avez été assez éclairant sur la
Société du Grand Paris en nous dressant
le portrait des relations qu'il pourrait
y avoir entre réseau et SGP mais vous
avez dit que
sVP ne serait là que pour construire du
réseau neuf qui sera ensuite apporté au
réseau ferroviaire national est-ce que
vous confirmez bien cette information
est-ce qu'elle est aussi précise parce
que moi je voyais dans cette proposition
du gouvernement
une idée assez complexe qui mettait en
concurrence
SNCF réseau du point de vue de la
gestion des infrastructures avec une
nouvelle entité alors merci de nous
confirmer cette information puis la
dernière question et j'en ai fini une ça
ferroviaire a proposé des Assises du
ferroviaire vous n'avez absolument pas
évoqué encore la question des ressources
humaines parmi nos 10 000 questions
j'aimerais un éclairage de ce côté là je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à Stéphane
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur Chabanel nous
auditionnons régulièrement les acteurs
du secteur ferroviaire et notamment à la
SNCF et je peux malheureusement
ressortir mes précédentes
d'interventions car mes demandes restent
similaires et si elles restent
similaires c'est que malheureusement les
choses ne bougent pas alors chacun y va
et c'est légitime ici de sa liste de
courses moi je vais pas vous demander
plus je vous demanderai simplement de
respecter le cahier des charges la
région des Hauts de France accuse
toujours en moyenne 10% de suppression
de train par jour avec un taux qui monte
jusqu'à 50% dans certains territoires
si en moyenne 10% des trains ne partent
pas ne serait-il pas juste que les
factures des collectivités soient
réduites de 10% j'entends bien que cette
question est simple assurément
provocante mais quelque part elle
apparaît aussi un peu légitime alors
comme cette demande au resto comme celle
de mon collègue marchand ne risque pas
d'aboutir j'en viens tout de suite et
directement ma deuxième question selon
une décision de SNCF réseau valider fin
février par la RT la redevance des
péages ferroviaires va augmenter de 8%
en 2024 puis la hausse sera de 4% en 25
et 26 la première explication est bien
sûr de répondre au contexte
inflationniste mais aussi de retrouver
un équilibre financier pour SNCF réseau
pour qui le prix des péages je crois et
la principale source de financement mais
au final au final qui va régler
l'addition car la redevance représente
40% je crois du prix d'un billet de
train et dans les prochains mois chaque
région devra donc décider si elle
encaisse seul cette majoration ou si
elle fait aussi peser
l'évolution sur les usagers il n'y a pas
36 solutions il faudra soit répercuter
la hausse des tarifs dans les billets
soit faire des économies en réduisant le
nombre de trajet sur certaines lignes et
quand on connaît les rames de train déjà
surbondés du TER Amiens Paris et les
conséquences de l'inflation sur le
quotidien des Français je ne peux que
penser à cette citation du dessinateur
Kino qui disait le pire c'est quand le
pire commence à empirer alors monsieur
le Président ma deuxième question est
très simple le pire va-t-il continuer à
empirer pour les habitants de mon
département de la Somme
merci la parole est à elle rigole
merci à Michel le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général de la SNCF
réseau moi c'est plutôt une remarque que
je vais vous faire plutôt qu'une
question
elle concerne cette remarque et la
suppression des passages à niveau
sur la ligne intersité par éclairement
il y a sur un linéaire assez court 14
suppressions qui sont théoriquement
possible sur un linéaire d'environ 30 km
je veux faire remonter les critiques et
maintenant du terrain comme vous le
savez la suppression de passage à niveau
n'est pas sans conséquence sur les
chemins routiers sur les aménagements
fonciers qui sont nécessaires je vais
mettre l'accent sur une concertation
indispensable différents acteurs du
territoire quand je parle de différents
acteurs du territoire je parle des mers
bien sûr mais aussi des conseils
départementaux des représentants de la
profession agricole
et puis concertation aussi sur le
partage des enjeux aujourd'hui il y a
une réelle incompréhension liée à la
nécessité de supprimer les passagers
niveau qui est assez mal comprises car
mal expliqué et souvent subi son
concertation alors j'insiste bien sûr
sur le sujet qui paraît peut-être
évident pour les usagers du train mais
beaucoup moins pour les différents
acteurs concernés sur les territoires à
qui on ne présente souvent que des
schémas de suppression des passages à
niveau et avec des échanges préables qui
sont à mon avis beaucoup trop limité
merci cher collègue j'ai donné la parole
à Hervé
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Chabanel je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention
concernant le rapport avec la Société du
Grand Paris un des sujets qui mis sur la
table aujourd'hui c'est la qualité du
reporting
la Société du Grand Paris mais en
évidence justement ces compétences en la
matière quand elle émet en évidence elle
met peut-être en creux
quelque part les interrogations qui peut
y avoir à votre sujet sur justement la
qualité du reporting de nombreux élus
régionaux le souligne également donc que
souhaitez-vous faire en la matière
comment quels sont vos stratégies
d'amélioration parce que visiblement il
y a un problème sur la qualité du
reporting
pour assurer un rapport de confiance
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
le deuxième sujet que je souhaitais
évoquer avec vous concerne quand vous
évoquez donc l'impact de la crise
climatique et des surveillances et des
adaptations en termes de résilience se
pose un problème aujourd'hui au niveau
de l'électrification et on s'aperçoit
que c'est un enjeu qui est absolument
majeur puisque avec la montée des
températures on est obligé aussi de
ralentir les trains parce que des
caténaires ne supportent pas certaines
élévations de température et notamment
il y a un problème aujourd'hui au niveau
des incendies du voltage qu'est-ce qui
est prévu en la matière c'est un sujet
qui est quand même majeur et qui
engendre un certain nombre de désordres
à l'heure actuelle et puis quand on
évoquait aussi la Société du Grand Paris
je voudrais y revenir sur les règles du
jeu que vous avez pu évoquer nous
serions particulièrement intéressés de
savoir s'il va y avoir une forme
d'accord cadre qui définirait les
modalités de partenariats entre
vous-même et donc la Société du Grand
Paris et pour nous en tant que
parlementaire nous serions
particulièrement intéressés à pouvoir
analyser ce document et en regarder
effectivement toutes les conditions
parce que les implications sont
particulièrement importantes je vous
remercie
j'avais pas prévu de lui donner la
parole mais comme c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui je vais proposer à notre
collègue Fabien Genet de vous interroger
monsieur
merci
monsieur le président
c'est bien la seule mesure d'âge qu'on
soit joyeux de fêter cette semaine
monsieur le Président de SNCF réseau mon
excellent collègue Bigot à parler d'une
expérimentation en Bourgogne
Franche-Comté qui est ma région sur les
faroucheurs je voudrais vous parler un
peu de l'effarouchements des passagers
que constitue l'état de la ligne
paray-le-moniale Lyon entre
Saône-et-Loire et Rhône entre Bourgogne
Franche-Comté et Auvergne Rhône-Alpes sa
fragilité ralentit le trafic des trains
est nécessite des travaux alors il y a
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
des problèmes de cadencement
d'irrégularité des trains une absence de
permanence de la SNCF à l'aiguillage de
La Mure en asiaque pour gérer le flux de
trafic mais également des problématiques
liées à l'infrastructure et
l'impossibilité de croisement sur un
tranchant à voix unique de 90 km entre
Lausanne et Paray-le-Monial et donc les
territoires sont extrêmement mobilisés
les quatre intercommunalités traversées
ont commandé d'ailleurs une étude sur la
mobilité et je crois crois que cette
ligne est intéressante dans ce qu'elle
représente et bien finalement le
désenclavement qu'elle pourrait
permettre d'une région proche d'une
métropole finalement ça pourrait être un
bon exemple de lien entre la métropole
et sa plaque métropolitaine pour
employer un terme utilisé par les
géographes pour l'instant on a plutôt
l'impression monsieur le Président qu'on
est à côté de la plaque mais on voudrait
effectivement se connecter beaucoup
mieux à la métropole et donc
observant que le maire de
Paray-le-Monial qui se bat pour cette
ligne depuis de très nombreuses années
en mairie ou au Parlement lorsqu'il
était député comme il fête son
anniversaire demain je me demandais si
éventuellement il y avait une bonne
nouvelle à lui offrir
considérant que pour ma part même si
c'est mon anniversaire cette aujourd'hui
la déontologie m'interdit de demander
quelques cadeaux que ce soit mais pour
le maire de Paray-le-Monial je me
permets de vous poser cette question
merci chers
monsieur le Président de la SNCF réseau
merci de votre présence moi je voulais à
l'instar de mes deux collègues vous
parlez de la situation dans la région
des Hautes France en effet après des
décennies de train supprimer de train en
retard de galère pour les usagers vous
avez et je n'oublie pas les parties de
bras de fer entre les élus et SNCF vous
avez vous avez décidé annoncé 500
millions d'euros d'investissement en
2023 pour rénover les infrastructures
ferroviaires dans la région des Hauts de
France on ne peut que s'en réjouir si ce
n'est sans satisfaire et cela fait
renaître de l'espérance sauf que les
syndicats disent qu'il manque à ce jour
200 personnes pour conduire les trains
dans la région des Hauts de France vous
l'avez évoqué il y a un énorme travail
d'attractivité à faire en matière de
ressources humaines et je voulais mettre
en évidence l'urgence amener ce travail
en tout cas dans la région des
Hauts-de-France ensuite je voulais
plutôt et c'est là vraiment mes deux
questions vous interrogez sur
l'interodalité et
j'attends de vous que vous me disiez si
c'est une vraie préoccupation pour SNCF
réseau en effet moi j'ai vu avec
beaucoup de tristesse
le
renoncement à deux plateformes
trimodales qui doivent accompagner le
canal senor le lien entre le fleuve le
rail et la route c'est alors que ce
canal senor représente un énorme enjeu
économique et un enjeu pour le
réchauffement climatique je m'interroge
sur le rôle que joue SNCF réseau dans le
renoncement assez plateformes deuxième
chose je viens de rencontrer les acteurs
des ports français des grands ports
français qui me disent que si on veut
supprimer à la source le flux de camions
et bien c'est dans les portes que ça se
joue et donc depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
avec Monsieur mandelier avec Monsieur
waspard on avait évoqué les
investissements à réaliser pour que le
transfert modal dans les ports se fasse
correctement or il semble me dit ces
acteurs économiques à ce jour pas grand
chose ne bouge malheureusement est-ce
que vous pouvez m'éclairer sur la
posture de SNCF réseau à ce propos merci
président monsieur le Président je vais
vous poser une question qui va vous
paraître marginal par rapport aux
interrogations de mes collègues
mais comme tous les gestionnaires de
réseau vous êtes soumis dans les
territoires qui sont
susceptibles de recevoir les feux à des
obligations légales de débroussaillement
je vous ai entendu dire que le
glyphosate était banni de l'utilisation
que vous aviez pour désherber les voies
je voudrais savoir comment maintenant
vous allez assurer ces obligations
légales de débroussaillement sachant que
les lignes sur lesquelles vous aviez ces
obligations
en fonction de l'évolution du climat
vont largement augmenter les kilomètres
vont largement augmenter voilà ma
question est là comment allez-vous
assurer ces obligations légales de
débroussaillement de façon à ce qu'on
est plus comme on l'a connu l'année
dernière à la montagne des départs de
feu qui partent de du réseau ferré
merci la parole est à Rémi Cointreau
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de SNCF réseau je
vais
malheureusement parler de mes courses
aussi
régionales et vous parlez de la ligne
Bourges Montluçon qui une ligne de type
Intervilles et qui fait le lien entre
deux régions Centre-Val de Loire et la
région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes c'est une
ligne de du quotidien des certes fines
du territoire et il y a une offre de
fret pour les céréales une offre
également pour les ateliers d'Orval où
on y fabrique des wagons où on y ressort
des wagons et puis aussi des voyageurs
or cette ligne est dans un état
déplorable aujourd'hui
beaucoup de bus sont affrétés à
Montluçon pour emmener les voyageurs
pour aller à Vierzon donc la ligne est
obsolète il y a un besoin de
régénération de 70 millions d'euros
la régénération selon une convention
entre les deux régions et SNCF réseau
donc devrait être prise en charge à 100%
par vos services monsieur le Président
en trois phases les travaux sont sans
cesse retardés ils doivent se faire avec
une ligne fermée pendant de nombreux
mois peut-être plusieurs années
je voulais savoir est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment des dates de prévues pour cette
régénération et est-ce que la
réintégration réseau structurant de la
ligne bourge Montluçon serait effective
en 2023 ou 2024 en fonction de de ce qui
a été prévu
merci je suis dans la parole à Guillaume
chevrolier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président SNCF réseau au
travers de votre religion de votre
audition pardon on voit bien les les
enjeux de l'amélioration de la
performance industrielle de votre groupe
tant le besoin d'indépendance que le
moyen financier notamment des moyens
financiers pour
assurer l'entretien et la modernisation
du réseau et notamment le point qui a
déjà été évoqué par des collègues mais
de la signalisation par rapport à aux
mises aux normes européennes et le
retard français ont la matière et qui
permettrait s'il était comblé de faire
circuler davantage de train tout en
garantissant la sécurité ce qui est
essentiel puisque
l'intensité des circulations en France
est plus faible que la moyenne
européenne ce qui est quand même un
signe d'un sous-investissement dans le
secteur donc les mesures sont attendues
et
notamment dans ma région donc permettait
moi aussi de parler de la région des
Pays de la Loire qui est une région qui
qui a subi l'abandon d'un projet
structurant alors pas fait revienne au
portuaire avec l'abandon de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes donc une forte
attente de compensation par l'État et
d'un soutien justement de dcncf réseau
pour faire face à une saturation de
ligne ligérienne et la nécessité de
moderniser des postes d'aiguillages
notamment et des systèmes de
signalisation informatisés c'est prévu
il y a un calendrier est-ce que il peut
y avoir
des travaux plus rapidement réalisés
pour faire face à une forte attente des
voyageurs notamment sur les liaisons
intra régional parce qu'une optimisation
de vitesse
favoriserait les mobilités des ligériens
et des mayennais en particulier
et en cette Journée mondiale de l'eau je
voudrais vous interroger sur la
politique de votre groupe sur la gestion
de l'eau dans un contexte de stress
hydrique et de nécessité de sobriété et
de
recyclage de l'eau enfin est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire une petite topo sur
votre politique de l'eau merci
merci chers collègues monsieur
merci
alors je je pour refaire les choses dans
dans l'ordre sur les interventions de
Monsieur devinas sur sur le frais
c'est vrai que le nœud ferroviaire
Lyonnet même si on va pas faire le
comité de pilotage ici et un nœud
stratégique pour le fret notamment
puisque tous les flux qui viennent du
sud ce qu'ils aillent vers Paris vers
l'Allemagne passe par le nœud ferrovi
Lyonnais et qu'aujourd'hui en l'absence
de contournement ferroviaire de
l'agglomération lyonnaise il passe au
milieu de la gare de la Part-Dieu et
donc on a là un goulet d'étranglement
sur le fret autant au sud on a des fois
à la fois en rive droite et en rive
gauche du Rhône autant à Lyon on a un
enjeu important de désaturation pour le
fret et donc
pardon et oui et naturellement vers
l'Italie venant du sud ou vers l'Italie
venant du nord on a cet enjeu là avec
toute la problématique des accès aux
futurs tunnel Lyon Turin ferroviaire
donc là on a vraiment un
enjeu de programmation de ces
investissements dans les dans les dans
les années à venir et de traitement de
s'écouler d'étranglement ça c'est pas
des travaux qui sont financés par SNCF
réseau on est bien sur des travaux de
développement donc ils doivent être
portés par l'État éventuellement les
collectivités
locales de manière à prévoir dans le
cadre des contrats de projets et ta
région ou dans le cadre d'une vision
plus nationale comme c'est le cas sur
les grands projets de prévoir les
investissements nécessaires pour autant
SNCF réseau à son rôle à jouer pour
faciliter pour faciliser les choses et
je pense notamment aux plateformes de
transport combinés à Lyon on est en
train d'investir sur le sur la
plateforme de transport combiné de
Vénissieux on est en train d'investir
sur le triage de ciblin donc la remise
en état de l'ensemble des installations
de fret elles doivent permettre dans des
sites stratégiques comme les
l'agglomération lyonnaises de développer
le frais de ferroviaire et de se
rapprocher de l'objectif du doublement
du frais de ferroviaire à l'horizon à
l'horizon 2030
lors des dernières années on a doublé
les investissements dans les voies de
service au cours des deux dernières
années et de la même manière on a
augmenté alors qu'on n'avait pas investi
depuis nombreuses années dessus les
investissements dans les dans les
triages dans les triages ferroviaires la
deuxième point d'intervention c'était
autour de l'accessibilité du réseau des
ruptures de charges et c'est c'est une
question qui m'a été aussi posée je
crois par Madame Monteil
on a là-dessus un enjeu essentiel
et dans la cadre de la problématique des
services express métropolitain c'est
quelque chose qui devrait être
pleinement intégré aussi bien par la
Société du Grand Paris par SNCF réseau
dans les études qui seront conduites
c'est comment on a des systèmes de
transport qui intègrent l'arrivée dans
le système ferroviaire donc SNCF réseau
a la chance aujourd'hui d'être d'avoir
comme filiale SNCF gare et connexion et
donc de travailler à la fluidité depuis
l'entrée dans la gare jusqu'au train
mais il faut travailler même en amont de
l'entrée dans la gare et travailler avec
les collectivités toutes les
problématiques de parking relais de
desserts par les services de bus ou par
les services de métro des gares on sait
qu'aujourd'hui notamment la coordination
entre les transports urbains et les
transports ferroviaires c'est souvent
quelque chose qui est pas tout à fait
abouti on a des métropoles où c'est très
au point et très abouti et on a d'autres
métropoles où ce dialogue là il a pas
encore eu tout à fait lieux et où il y a
il peut y avoir des aménagements
nécessaires aussi bien côté côté urbain
que côté ferroviaire donc c'est
effectivement la question de cet
accessibilité du transport ferroviaire à
un en essentiel ça passe aussi par la
mise en accessibilité là j'allais dire
cette fois-ci vis-à-vis des personnes à
mobilité réduite de nos gares et de nos
et de nos trains parce que il faut que
le parcours soit le plus fluide possible
et les personnes à mobilité réduite
c'est pas seulement les personnes en
situation de handicap c'est aussi toutes
les personnes qui ont des qui se les
personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des
poussettes et des enfants les personnes
enfin voilà le chant de du besoin
d'avoir un parcours fluide en termes
d'accessibilité il concerne des millions
et des millions de personnes et donc si
on veut vraiment que le train trouve
toute sa place dans les mobilités il
faut qu'on rentre ce parcours le plus
fluide possible ça nécessite un travail
étroit entre SNCF réseau SNCF gare et
connexion mais aussi les collectivités
métropolitaines pour faciliter cet accès
alors ensuite sur les questions de
Monsieur monsieur Bigot sur les étoiles
ferroviaires et les services express
métropolitain effectivement il y a 10
sites qui ont été cités par le Président
de la République la manière je ne sais
pas vous dire aujourd'hui la manière
dont le gouvernement mais je pense que
ce sera annoncé dans les prochaines dans
les prochaines semaines dans le
gouvernement souhaite ouvrir le chant de
la discussion sur les services express
métropolitain notamment dans le cadre
des dialogues des contrats de projet
état région et comment on détermine les
les sites sur lesquels ces services
express métropolitains
se mettent en place quels sont les
critères qui définissent un service
express métropolitain ça ça fait partie
des choses qui sont encore devant nous
entre maintenant et la conclusion des
contrats de projet est en région
notamment
s'agissant des effaroucheurs pour le
pour le gibier vous savez que le que le
que le la croissance du grand gibier et
une préoccupation alors pour le monde
agricole mais aussi beaucoup pour le
monde des transports on a aujourd'hui
2 millions de sangliers abattus chaque
année là où on en avait 300 000 au début
des années des années des années 80 donc
on a eu une progression exponentielle du
du nombre du nombre de sangliers donc on
cherche à faire toutes les actions
possibles pour limiter donc on a testé
on est en train de tester ces
dispositifs des faroucheurs qui sont
dédiés pour pour l'ensemble de d'entre
vous qui sont des dispositifs qui font
que quand un train arrive il y a un
dispositif sonore qui se met en place et
qui est censé faire en sorte que le
sanglier ne traverse pas la voix à ce
moment-là ça paraît
une méthode qui peut porter ses fruits
on a essayé d'autres méthodes notamment
avec des catadioptres des choses
visuelles ça n'a pas marché donc on
essaye cette méthode là et l'autre
méthode c'est aussi de mettre des
clôtures et notamment sur la ligne qui
est particulièrement frappée aujourd'hui
entre Angers enfin entre sablés Angers
et énorme sur lequel on a eu une
croissance très très forte
l'automne dernier l'hiver dernier du
nombre de heures notamment sur les
sangliers de sangliers sur les sur les
trains Paris-Nantes on va aussi
renforcer la politique de développement
de clôture qui ne va pas sans difficulté
parce que il y a des trames de
biodiversité qui doivent être préservées
on n'a pas le droit de mettre des
clôtures partout et il faut surtout pas
que les sangliers se retrouvent coincés
entre deux clôtures parce que là ils
sont coincés sur la voie donc faut leur
permettre de ressortir donc c'est c'est
problématique là qui peuvent paraître
peut-être un peu pincement matériel mais
c'est les problématiques auxquelles sont
confrontées chaque jour les ingénieurs
hommes et femmes de SNCF réseau pour
concevoir des solutions qui permettent
d'améliorer la qualité de service si les
effets rougeurs marchent on les
déploiera naturellement sur tous les
axes ou c'est nécessaire
[Musique]
j'en viens
aux questions portant sur les sur les
hauts de France alors sur les
Hauts-de-France je suis désolé mais je
vais pas je vais pas pouvoir répondre
aux questions qui portent sur les
conducteurs de train puisque SNCF réseau
n'est pas porteur de des
enfin j'entends les questions je
comprends les difficultés je peux pas
m'exprimer pour pour pour
SNCF voyageur j'en suis j'en suis
vraiment j'en suis vraiment désolé pour
autant ce que je peux dire concernant le
réseau en haut de France c'est que
d'abord on a augmenté le niveau
d'investissement sur le on a augmenté le
niveau d'investissement sur le réseau
que ce soit les investissements financés
par SNCF réseau les investissements
portés par la Région et l'État qui ont
eu des investissements très importants
je pense notamment à la remise en état
de l'ensemble de l'étoile ferroviaire de
Saint-Paul qui a été très largement
portée par la région Hauts-de-France qui
est aujourd'hui et une opération qui est
terminée et qui a permis d'avoir sur des
lignes de desserts de films du
territoire à un réseau qui aujourd'hui
en bien meilleur état qui ne l'était
côté SNCF réseau on a des opérations de
modernisation on va par exemple au
deuxième semestre de cette année refaire
les voies entre Rouen et Amiens on a
refait il y a peu le les tunnels à la
sortie d'Amiens enfin voilà on a
beaucoup d'opérations importantes sur le
réseau des Hauts de France pour
améliorer la qualité de service dont on
est conscient qu'elle est aujourd'hui
pas au rendez-vous sur le sujet des
lignes fermées on est tout à fait
disposé à en transférer la gestion pour
mettre en place des voies vertes des du
cyclotourisme des modes de transport en
commun on l'a fait dans de nombreuses
régions on est très disposés à le faire
souvent on préfère faire un transfert de
gestion de manière à pas opérer l'avenir
par exemple par rapport à des projets
qui seraient des projets de lotissement
ou d'urbanisation sur des espaces où on
pourrait se dire peut-être dans 20 ans
dans 30 ans dans 50 ans on serait
content de garder une liaison
qui puisse réunion prise qui puisse
redevenir ferroviaire donc souvent on
privilégie le transfert de gestion mais
mais on est tout à fait favorable à des
transferts de gestion pour faire des
tramways des voies vertes des lotourisme
tout autre mode et si il y a des projets
je suis tout à fait prêt à les
transmettre à mes équipes et à
travailler avec vous à ce type de projet
j'en viens en question de Monsieur de
Monsieur Jacquin s'agissant
du nouveau du contrat de performance je
pense qu'effectivement on va pas rester
sur un contrat vraiment ce qui prévoit
trois milliards si on prévoit 4
milliards et demi donc il y aura une
révision du contrat de performance dans
un calendrier rapproché qui devra se
mettre en place il y a eu le temps des
annonces à la fin du mois de février il
y a le temps de la mise en place à
l'horizon du mois de juin et ensuite il
faudra traduire ça dans un document
d'une manière d'une manière ou d'une
autre puisque nous derrière on va passer
des marchés longue durée avec des
industriels on va réserver des capacités
pour faire des travaux donc il y aura
nécessairement ce travail là qui qui
sera qui est à conduire et qui est qui
est devant nous et à laquelle auquel on
se prépare
en associant le en associant le
Parlement sur Noé modalités qui seront
qui seront qui seront calés entre le
gouvernement et le Parlement tout à fait
s'agissant de la Société du Grand Paris
raisonnable réseau ferrés national
la Société du Grand Paris aujourd'hui
pour le réseau
du Grand Paris Express elle ne prévoit
pas d'être exploitante ce réseau demain
demain elle est en transférera la
gestion de l'infrastructure à la RATP et
les circulations seront gérées par un
exploitant qui va être choisi par
Île-de-France mobilité donc il n'y a pas
de raison enfin il y a pas de
revendication de sa part de devenir dans
la durée un gestionnaire
d'infrastructures de morceaux du réseau
ferré national l'intérêt de la Société
du Grand Paris il est triple c'est la
construction d'infrastructures neuves
sur lequel ils ont une vraie expertise
c'est les phases d'études sur lequel là
aussi et notamment pour l'interface avec
la ville ils ont une vraie expertise et
où ils peuvent apporter beaucoup de
choses et le modèle financier de la
Société du Grand Paris qui aussi des
collectivités sont intéressés par sa
duplication pourrait les intéresser ça
me permet de répondre aussi à la
question que
naturellement les modalités
d'intervention de la Société du Grand
Paris elles vont nécessiter une
modification des de ces statuts et comme
les statuts de la Société du Grand Paris
sont fixés par la loi il y aura
forcément une association du Parlement à
un moment si on veut sortir du principe
de spécialité de la Société du Grand
Paris qui pour le moment ne peut
travailler quand quand l'Île-de-France
donc là dessus
s'agissant
[Musique]
de de l'INSA des métiers ferroviaires je
pense avoir un système à plusieurs
reprises sur les hommes et les femmes de
de et le fait que c'était une condition
un prérequis à nos ambitions que d'avoir
des salariés au sein de la SNCF réseau
et plus largement au sein de la filière
qui trouve un épanouissement
professionnel que ça passait par notre
activité de la filière que ça passait
par des enjeux de formation et
qu'ensuite ça peut passer par des enjeux
de fidélisation et donc les
fidélisations s'apportent sur les
conditions de travail ça porte sur
l'intérêt des métiers ça porte sur le
déroulement des carrières tout ça c'est
des enjeux qui sont vraiment au cœur des
préoccupations de la SNCF réseau
aujourd'hui parce que c'est une
condition impérative pour réussir la
monter en puissance des investissements
[Musique]
c'est de la performance annuelle il faut
qu'on atteigne nos objectifs de
performance ensuite sur le financement
il y a un équilibre à trouver entre les
péages et les subventions ça fera partie
de l'objet des discussions sur le
financement du média ennemi
complémentaire qui doivent être menées
dans les dans les mois qui viennent mais
SNCF réseau n'a pas d'autres ressources
que les pH et les subventions
s'agissant des suppressions de passage à
niveau j'ai bien pris le le sujet je
reviendrai vers les équipes pour leur
redire la nécessité d'associer
l'ensemble des acteurs et c'est vrai que
la suppression des dépassages au niveau
elle a un intérêt direct pour le
ferroviaire mais elle doit prendre en
compte les mobilités routières ou
piétonnières ou par tout autre par tout
autre mode qui empruntent ces passages à
niveau avant de de passer de passer au
suppression
s'agissant des questions de Monsieur
gilet sur la qualité du reporting
bah oui on a des progrès et je les dis
dans mon propos liminaire on a des
progrès à faire dans la qualité du
reporting de SNCF réseau aujourd'hui
SNCF réseau livre 96% de ses projets
dans les délais et livre 80% de projets
en économie et 20% de projets en surco
20% de projets en surcoût c'est beaucoup
trop il faut qu'on réussisse à diminuer
ce nombre de projets mais il y a une
chose qui est encore plus importante
insupportable que de livrer un projet en
surcoût c'est de pas avoir prévenu qu'on
allait être en surco et donc il faut
réussir à mettre en place des reportings
et on a un projet qu'on a lancé qui
s'appelle excellence projet qui vise à
s'améliorer sur le fond mais à
s'améliorer aussi dans la capacité à
rendre compte au financeur d'un projet
très en amont des difficultés qu'on
rencontre des risques du projet et des
et de laisser des choix dans la manière
de traiter ces risques et de manière à
être plus PROACT trouve plus efficace
c'est vraiment un enjeu important et je
reconnais que là-dessus il y a des
progrès à faire du côté de SNCF réseau
mais on s'y emploie vraiment et dans la
nouvelle génération des contrats de
projets et ta région ou des grands
projets je souhaite que ce projet soit
ressenti par tout les financeurs de nos
projets c'est vraiment une ambition
importante pour moi
sur la crise climatique et
l'électrification c'est vrai que sur les
électrifications les plus anciennes je
pense à la caténaire midi dans le sud
gironde je pense à la caténaire sur la
ligne C du RER sur les élites et donc le
nord de la ligne Paul puisque la ligne C
du RER c'est la sortie de Paris par la
gare d'Austerlitz
sur ces électrifications les plus
anciennes qui datent souvent des années
30 on a un sujet plus compliqué avec les
fortes chaleurs et donc là les
investissements de régénération vont
viser à remplacer ces caténaires mais
c'est des programmes qui s'étaleront
dans le temps probablement sur une
dizaine d'années au moins à remplacer
ces caténaires par des caténaires plus
modernes et résistant mieux aux
variations de température importantes
pour nous c'est un enjeu c'est un enjeu
important et essentiel pour la
résilience pour la résilience du réseau
[Musique]
mais bien déterminé à mon avis à
l'échelle territoriale sans doute sur la
base de quelques grands principes
arrêtés à l'échelle à l'échelle
nationale
sur les questions de Monsieur Genet
d'abord bon anniversaire
et ensuite
s'agissant de la ligne de
Paray-le-Monial à Lyon donc là on est
sur une ligne de dessert fin du
territoire il y a déjà eu un projet à un
première phase de modernisation entre
parer le Monial et Lausanne il y a 4-5
ans je pense à peu près il faut qu'au
prochain CPER on est une nouvelle phase
de modernisation donc ça ça c'est
essentiel donc il faut qu'on mette
autour de la table les deux régions les
deux préfets et SNCF réseau autour d'un
projet commun puisque sur ces projets de
ligne de dessert film du territoire
l'essentiel du financement et apporté
par les régions et et par l'État et SNCF
réseau et un financeur très minoritaire
à hauteur de 8 et demi pour cent nous on
peut amener des solutions techniques
mais il faut vraiment qu'on ait une
entente des collectivités pour se dire
la priorité a donné à la modernisation à
la modernisation de cette ligne
sauf à réintégrer cette ligne dans le
réseau structurant mais c'est pas le
choix qui a été retenu jusqu'à présent
donc
donc donc voilà
s'agissant des questions de Madame fille
alors sur les hauts de France j'ai
répondu même si
sur l'intermodalité je pense avoir
répondu aussi
alors vis-à-vis des ports français il
est effectivement enfin on a je suis pas
le seul mais beaucoup d'acteurs du
ferroviaire ont la conviction que une
source importante de la croissance du
ferroviaire va passer par les ports
français et une source importante de la
croissance des ports français va passer
par leur bonne desserts de ferroviaire
donc il y a vraiment un travail étroit à
faire à faire entre nous en la matière
sur ce sujet sur les infrastructures
ferroviaires dans les ports elles ont
été transférées aux ports donc elles
sont à la main des enfin c'est au port
de déterminer ensuite sur la desserte
ultérieure on a des projets importants
de modernisation je pense à un projet
qui a été mis en service en 2021 entre
Paris et le port du Havre qui est le
contournement par cercuegisor sur lequel
on a électrifié la ligne c'est 300
millions d'investissements portés par la
région de France et le et la et l'État
qui permettent une meilleure desserte du
corps ensuite il faut qu'on réfléchisse
aux plateformes de transport combiné
j'ai récemment
signer le lancement avec le président de
la région Normandie et le président de
la Région Centre Val de Loire et le
président du daropa donc il réunit port
du Havre de Rouen et de Paris d'une
plateforme à Orléans qui permettent de
service de base arrière au port
ferroviaire au port au port normand et
donc ce type de projet là il faut
vraiment qu'on les développe et qu'on
les multiplie et donc on travaille entre
SN le réseau à l'effort à où est-ce
qu'ils ont besoin de base arrière
ferroviaire pour les développer ensemble
et qu'on réussisse à faire venir de
l'initiative privée pour financer ces
bases arrières ferroviaires parce que il
y a des acteurs privés de la logistique
qui sont intéressés à mettre des
financements et une époque où les
financements publics sont rares il faut
absolument qu'on réussisse à attirer ces
financements privés
s'agissant la question de Monsieur
batchy sur le sur le sur le
débroussaillage c'est un enjeu essentiel
on veut pas revivre nous non plus ce qui
s'est passé à la Montagnette et on sait
que effectivement il peut y avoir
parfois des freins serrés sur des trains
notamment sur les trains de fret qui
créent des étincelles et qui se
débroussaillage a pas été suffisamment
fait puisse constituer des débuts
d'incendie donc quand je dis qu'on est
sorti du glyphosate on a quand même
remplacé le glyphosate par un produit
qui est essentiellement un produit
bio-contrôle qui est l'acide pélagonique
donc on doit passer plus souvent ça nous
coûte plus cher mais on continue à
désherber et en zone de non traitement
et bien il faut qu'on fasse du
traitement manuel de la végétation mais
on est bien conscient des impératifs
qu'on a et ça rejoint la question de la
résilience climatique avec des
sécheresses de plus nombreuses etc de
conserver ces impératifs de
débroussaillage s'agissant des questions
de Monsieur point trop sur la ligne
bourgement Luçon donc cette ligne va
être en travaux à partir du lait de
l'été 2023 pour plusieurs mois avec un
financement porté par l'État et les
collectivités et elle intégrera en 2024
le réseau ferré national structurant et
donc ensuite ce sera SNCF réseau de
poursuivre ses projets pour maintenir en
état et relever le niveau de cette ligne
notamment relever les limitations de
vitesse qui aujourd'hui existe sur cette
sur cette ligne
s'agissant
des questions relatives à notre
performance industrielle nos moyens
financiers
[Musique]
monsieur chevrolier oui et sur les Pays
de la Loire et là et les suites de
l'abandon de de du projet de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes donc
la
on a un enjeu effectivement de réussir
les projets qui font suite à la à
l'abandon de notre âme des Landes il y a
une partie de ces projets qui se
tiennent en région Pays de la Loire
c'est la ça passe par la remise en état
d'infrastructures ça passe par des
clôtures etc etc il y a aussi des
projets clés qui sont dans le sud de
l'agglomération parisienne notamment on
a une section de ligne qu'il faut
doubler entre Massy et Valenton pour
permettre une bonne desserte entre les
régions Bretagne Pays de la Loire et les
aéroports parisiens c'est un projet sur
lequel il y a un le montage d'un
financement en cours entre l'État les
régions Pays de la Loire Bretagne et
Île-de-France et donc ça c'est des
projets qui sont bien sur le dessus de
la pile des projets de de de SNCF réseau
s'agissant de la Journée mondiale de
l'eau
deux sujets de d'action côté SNCF réseau
d'un côté participé aux économies d'eau
notamment par la remise en état de nos
bâtiments vous savez qu'on a un parc
immobilier de plusieurs millions de
mètres carrés qu'il faut qu'on mette en
état progressivement de manière à
diminuer nos consommations et d'énergie
et de fluide et donc ça c'est un moyen
de diminuer les consommations d'eau et
en matière d'eau notre haute
préoccupation c'est comment nos
infrastructures
résistent aux inondations plus
fréquentes plus fortes qu'on peut
rencontrer sur le réseau on a eu
notamment en région Languedoc-Roussillon
des événements très puissants qui ont
interrompu les circulations pendant
plusieurs semaines en emportant la
plateforme ferroviaire avec des
problématiques de ruissellement on a eu
naturellement les événements de la
vallée de la de la Roya comment est-ce
qu'on prend le réseau plus résilient aux
enjeux hydriques qui peuvent
hydrologiques qui peuvent intervenir
voilà ce que je pouvais indiquer
monsieur
bien merci monsieur le Président
Directeur Général merci pour cette
audition ce moment des échanges je crois
que les questions étaient riches
importantes et vous avez
répondu à l'ensemble des questions je
sais pas si toutes les réponses ont été
satisfaisantes pour nos collègues qui
les ont posés mais au moins ça le mérite
d'avoir cet échange et de et de répondre
à nos questions et je j'ai pu constater
effectivement à travers vos réponses que
vous aviez au moins quelque chose de
particulièrement fort et important c'est
que vous connaissez bien vous avez dit
qu'il faut bien connaître la géographie
je crois que vous connaissez bien la
géographie et que vous connaissez bien
le territoire national et vous
connaissez bien les lignes qui
desservent nos départements merci
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
et bonne continuation et puis à bientôt
merci monsieur le Président merci à
toutes et à tous vous ne parlez pas
parce qu'il y a encore deux questions à
l'ordre du jour
merci